ओके सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव आई थिंक वी आर
लाइव लेट मी सी
गाइस देखते हैं आज हमारा टारगेट कंप्लीट
होता है कि
नहीं बाकी चलिए वेलकम एवरी बडी एंड आई होप
आई एम क्लियर ऑडिबल एंड
विजिबल तो एक बार मुझे बता दीजिए सभी लोग
एम आई ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल एम आई
क्लियर ऑडियो वीडियो दोनों सही है बता
दीजिए जरा जल्दी से फटाफट बता दीजिए फटाफट
बता दीजिए जल्दी से एंड आने देते
सबको ओके लेट मी
चेक
लेट मी चेक लेट मी
चेक ओके सो एवरीथिंग
गुड या या या या या ओके ओके
ओके चलिए काफी लोग आ चुके
हैं ओके
ग्रेट
चलिए आज तो धमाका होने वाला है
बट 35 ओनली बाकी लोग कहां गए यार आज का आज
का सेशन बहुत खतरनाक होने वाला है भाई आ
जाओ चलो 48 सो वेलकम एवरीबॉडी वे कम वेलकम
टू द सेशन वेलकम टू डे नाइन ऑफ बग
बाउंटीज सभी का स्वागत है भाई यहां पर डे
नाइन में आप
सबका
ओ ग्रेट
[संगीत]
चलिए यस क्लाउड वाला आज क्लाउड वाला बट आज
सिर्फ 50 लोग ने ही जवाइन करा है अभी तक
बाकी हम थोड़े और लोग आने देते हैं थोड़े
और आ जाएंगे तभी स्टार्ट करेंगे मैंने
आपको बोला था ना 200 प्लस आज के टारगेट हम
रखते हैं बट थोड़े और अभी आने देते हैं
एंड आज हम बहुत खतरनाक बहुत धमाका करने
वाले हैं बहुत कुछ होने वाला है ठीक
है हां जी हां जी आज आज क्लाउड के नाम पर
है ये
कटिंग
ओके
चलिए सो गुड इवनिंग एवरीबॉडी वेलकम टू डे
नाइन ऑफ फ्री बग बाउंट कोर्स एंड आज हम इस
अ आज के दिन हम क्लाउड में कैसे सेटअप
करना है अपना पूरा लैब सेटअप कैसे करना है
कैसे आप क्लाउड में बग हंटिंग कर सकते हो
बग बाउंट हंटिंग करोगे जिससे आपकी
एफिशिएंसी और आपकी स्पीड दोनों ही काफी
एनहांस हो जाएगी एंड चांसेस विल इंक्रीज
टू फाइंड वैलिड बग अ
मोर सून दन डिफरेंट अदर बाउंट हंटर्स ठीक
है तो आपको जल्दी मिलने के चांसेस जो है
बाउंट या रिवॉर्ड स्वैग बढ़ जाते हैं
क्योंकि वीपीएस या क्लाउड में जब आप मशीन
यूज करते हो बहुत ही कंपेरटिवली फास्ट
होती है आपके लोकल मशीन के
दैट्ची लाइक नहीं आ पाते हैं नहीं आप लाइव
नहीं लेते हैं तो बहुत मतलब बहुत ज्यादा
कुछ मिस कर देंगे आप लाइव में जो आज का
मजा है ना वह फिर कहीं नहीं है यार आज का
लाइव जो है वह सबसे ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग है
सबसे ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग
है ओके देखता हूं मैं य पर मैसेज देख रहा
हूं मैं आप लोगों
के
चलिए चलिए तो करते स्टार्ट करने के
पहले स्टार्ट करने के पहले यहां पर एक
छोटी सी अनाउंसमेंट में
आपको यहां पर जस्ट
वेट काफी लोगों के क्वेश्चंस आ रहे हैं य
पर काफी सारे सर डेबिट या क्रेडिट कार्ड
इन दिस स्ट्रीम डेबिट कार्ड मैंने आपको
ऑलरेडी बोला था चैनल प अगर आपने जवाइन कर
लिया होगा तो आपको पता होना चाहिए यह चीज
चैनल प आपने जवाइन नहीं करा है क्या इसका
मतलब
हमारा डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक का कंप्लीट एक थ्री
मंथ्स का लाइव ट्रेनिंग प्रोग्राम स्टार्ट
हुआ है जो 27th जन से स्टार्ट हो रही है
क्लास उसकी एंड अभी प्री बुकिंग चल रही है
एंड सबसे अफोर्डेबल आपको मिलने वाला है
डिजिट फरसी की लाइव ट्रेनिंग यहां पे आपको
लिंक मैंने दे दिया है चैट में आप चैट में
देख सकते हैं आपको लिंक मिल गया है डिनीस
अकेडमी के तरफ से उस लिंक प आप आएंगे तो
यू विल कम टू दिस प्लेस सारी डिटेल्स आपको
यहां मिल जाएगी एंड आप इसमें सारी डिटेल्स
पढ़ के मॉड्यूस पढ़ के प्री बुक कर सकते
हैं ठीक है है तो डिजिटल फॉरन सिक्स अगर
देखो जैसे ट्राई हैक मी पे मैं चलता हूं
आपको मैं आपको एक चीज दिखा देता हूं ट्राई
हैक मी पे चलोगे आप लर्निंग पाथ पे आ जाते
हैं ठीक है लर्निंग पाथ पे यहां पे
लर्निंग पाथ पे जब आप
आओगे यहां जब एसओसी एसओसी का लर्निंग पाथ
ओपन करोगे आप तो एसओसी के लर्निंग पाथ में
जब नीचे की तरफ आप आओगे तो यहां पे डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक का एक अलग ही सेक्शन है डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक की रिक्वायरमेंट आपको साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में भी है साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेशन में भी है डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक
इन्वेस्ट गेशन में भी है एंड एसोसी
एनालिस्ट अगर आप बनते हैं या बनना चाहते
हैं उसमें भी है ठीक है तो आपको यह पूरी
ट्रेनिंग इस तरह के अफोर्डेबल रेट में
कहीं नहीं मिलने वाली है एक बहुत अच्छा
अपॉर्चुनिटी है गो ग्रैब दिस अपॉर्चुनिटी
जल्दी से कर लीजिए अभी ऑफर फी अभी चल रही
है अभी आपकी एंड आपको ज्यादा आपको सिर्फ
यहां देखो आप इनरोल पे क्लिक करोगे आपको
सिर्फ 3500 ही पे करने हैं प्री बुकिंग
में रिमेनिंग 3500 आपको वन मंथ के बाद ही
पे करने हैं सो इट्स अन गोल्डन
अपॉर्चुनिटी ग्रो एंड ग्रैब दैट ठीक है
चलिए अब दिक्कत क्या आ रही थी भाई मैं
आपको दिक्कत की बात बताता हूं दिक्कत क्या
आ रही थी हमारे वह दिक्कत पहले हम समझते
हैं जब हम लोकल सिस्टम पर बग बांटी कर रहे
थे मैं यहां पे इसको चीज करता हूं लोकल
सिस्टम पे हम जब बग बांटी की लैब सेटअप कर
रहे थे करा था हमने एंड इस पे जब हम बग
बाउंट कर रहे थे लोकल सिस्टम पे उस टाइम
हमें दिक्कत क्या आ रही थी मुझ आप लोग
बताइए इस टाइम आप में जो भी लोग बग बाउटी
कर रहेंगे जो भी जो भी लोग यहां पे हंटिंग
कर रहे होंगे लोकल सिस्टम पे सबको यह
दिक्कत आ रही होगी दिक्कत यह आ रही होगी
भैया कि आपको आपको यहां पे स्पीड की
प्रॉब्लम आ रही होगी जैसे आप सब डोमेन
न्यूमरेशन कर रहे हो तो बहुत स्लो हो रहा
है डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग कर रहे हो
बहुत स्लो हो रहा है मतलब कुछ भी कर रहे
हो स्लो हो रहा है स्क्रीनशॉटिंग कर रहे
हो बहुत स्लो हो रहा है भैया तो फास्ट
कैसे किया जाए दो ही तरीका एक तो इंटरनेट
कनेक्टिविटी बहुत फास्ट होनी चाहिए पहली
चीज दूसरी क्या होनी चाहिए कि आपके पास एक
अच्छे हाई कॉन्फिन पटॉप होनी चाहिए जहां
पे कोई रैम का इशू ना आए ग्राफिक्स का इशू
ना आए सब एकदम बढ़िया से चल जाए अब इसमें
क्या है बहुत दिक्कत है सब लोगों के पास
नहीं होता और इतना बहुत ज्यादा हाई
इंटरनेट आप यूज़ करोगे हाई स्पीड इंटरनेट
का खर्चा बहुत ज्यादा आएगा 000 ₹ आ जाएंगे
महीने के ₹1500000
करके आप उस क्लाउड में एक बहुत ही फास्ट
इंटरनेट का यूज कर सकते हो एंड उस इंटरनेट
के अंदर में जो मशीन या जो ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम चाहिए वो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इंस्टॉल
कर सकते हो और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जब इंस्टॉल
कर लोगे तो उसमें तुम चलाओ और उसमें जो
स्पीड मिलेगी वो तुम्हारे दिमाग को हिला
के रख देगी वो स्पीड बग बाउंट हंटिंग में
चाहिए हमें एक्चुअल में अब सब लोग एफोर्ड
नहीं कर पाएंगे तो जो बिगनर है आप बेसिक
लोकल सिस्टम पे भी काम कर सकते हैं मैं ये
नहीं बोल रहा कि आपको क्लाउड ही चाहिए याद
रखिएगा थोड़ा स्लो होगा सीखने के लिए
अच्छा है बट जैसे-जैसे आपका लेवल बढ़ता
जाएगा आप इंटरमीडिएट एडवांस लेवल पे आते
जाएंगे यू विल बी नीडिंग ऑफ वीपीएस यू विल
बी नीडिंग अ क्लाउड सॉल्यूशन उसके बिना
काम नहीं हो पाएगा आप जितने देन में जितने
सब डोमेन फाइंड करोगे उससे कई गुना फास्ट
जो है ना कोई दूसरा बंदा वो सब डोमेन
फाइंड कर लेगा और वैसे सब डोमेंस एंड वैसे
अ वनबिल फाइंड करेगा जो आपको अभी मिले
नहीं होंगे आपको मिलेंगे फ्यूचर में वो
पहले ही कर चुका होगा क्यों क्योंकि पास
उसके पास स्पीड है उसके पास क्लाउड है ठीक
है
चलिए अब मैंने आप सबसे पूछा था आप सबसे
मैंने ैनू था किन-किन लोगों का एडब्ल्यू
एस अकाउंट बन गया डेबिट कार्ड से उन्होंने
करा रप के आसपास ट्रांजैक्शन हुए होंगे ₹
के आसपास कट हुआ होगा एंड उनका अकाउंट बन
गया होगा कितने लोगों का बन चुका है जरा
मुझे चैट में बता दीजिए मैं भी देख लू एक
बार लेट मी नो इन द चैट
प्लीज जल्दी से चैट में बता दीजिए कितने
लोगों का बन चुका है लेट मी सी द
चैट
फास्ट फास्ट जल्दी बताइए स्पीड स्लो आ रही
है क्या आज इंटरनेट की मेरी स्पीड ज्यादा
कुछ खास नहीं आ रही है लग रहा आज थोड़ी
स्लो है ठीक ठाक है ठीक है कि किन किन का
हो गया है ओके गर्वित का हो चुका है
बढ़िया शांके ओके ठीक है शांके का हुआ है
गर्वित का हुआ
है निखिल पहले से ही यूज कर रहा था ठीक है
बढ़िया निखिल
अ नहीं बना ठीक है नहीं बना ठीक है देखो
ओके इंटरनेशनल ट्रांजैक्शन नॉट अलाउड
इंटरनेशनल ट्रांजैक्शन अलाउड कर सकते हो
आप लोग अपना अपना कार्ड में इंटरनेशनल
ट्रांजैक्शन अलाउ कर सकते हो ठीक है वो
क्या होता है आपके सेटिंग में हो जाता है
जैसे एसबीआई का आपका अकाउंट है तो ो
एसबीआई ओपन कीजिएगा उसमें एटीएम डेबिट
कार्ड पे जाके मैनेज पे जाके वहां पे
इंटरनेशनल नेशनल इनेबल डिसेबल कर सकते हैं
एडीएफसी में भी मैनेज कार्ड पे कर सकते
हैं आईसीआईसीआई में भी जाएंगे तो आपको
मैनेज कार्ड करने का ऑप्शन मिलता है वहां
इंटरनेशनल नेशनल जो भी है वो इनेबल डिसेबल
कर सकते हैं या तो
हां अब देखिए चलिए मैं अब आपको एक चीज
बताता हूं अब एक चीज बताता हूं सबसे पहले
आप लोगों को एडब्ल्यू ए
amazonbusiness.in तो
एड्ड amazon.com फ वाले अकाउंट प पेज पर
आप आ जाते हैं ठीक है एंड यहां पर क्रिएट
अ फ्री अकाउंट प आपको क्लिक करना है एक
अकाउंट क्रिएट करने के लिए यह जो अकाउंट
आपका क्रिएट होगा यह एक फ्री अकाउंट
क्रिएट होगा ठीक है टोटली फ्री बट अब यहां
पर कैच क्या है मैं आपको बताता हूं जब आप
अकाउंट को क्रिएट कर रहे होंगे उस टाइम पर
यह आपके कार्ड को वेरीफाई करता है एक बार
आपको एक डेबिट कार्ड या क्रेडिट कार्ड की
रिक्वायरमेंट पर पती है डेबिट या क्रेडिट
कार्ड की रिक्वायरमेंट पड़ती है अब यह बात
मैं आपको इसलिए मैंने
भैया कैसे होगा मतलब कि डेबिट कार्ड आपको
कौन सा लगेगा क्या होगा वैसे डेबिट कार्ड
जो वैसे डेबिट कार्ड जो इंटरनेशनल
ट्रांजैक्शन अलाउ करते हो ये सारे कार्ड्स
जैसे कि एसबीआई एचडीएफसी
आईसीआईसीआई
अ उसके बाद आपका और भी ये बहुत सारे
कार्ड्स हैं यार कोटेक का भी है ये सारे
कार्ड्स ये इंटरनेशनल ट्रांजैक्शंस जो है
इनेबल आपके करते हैं एंड इंटरनेशनल
ट्रांजैक्शंस को अलाउ करते हैं ठीक है तो
आप इन कोई से भी डेबिट कार्ड को यूज कर
सकते हैं व्हिच हैज लेस मनी लेस मनी थोड़े
कम पैसे हो जिसमें थोड़े कम पैसे लेस मनी
ज्यादा पैसे वाले डेबिट कार्ड भी यूज मत
कीजिएगा मतलब ऐसा कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं आएगा
बट स्टिल आप वैसा ही कार्ड यूज कीजिए पैसे
थोड़े कम रहते हो मतलब दो 1000 000 ऐसे दो
3000 रहते हो बस
दैट्ची आपका डेबिट नहीं होगा डेबिट कार्ड
से वो क्रेडिट कार्ड से हो जाता लेकिन
डेबिट कार्ड से नहीं होगा डेबिट कार्ड का
आप यूज कीजिए ठीक
है हां रुपए कार्ड नहीं लेता है नो रुपए
कार्ड ये याद रखिएगा नो रुपए कार्ड ओनली
वीजा और मास्टर कार्ड को ही ट्राई कीजिएगा
वीजा या मास्टर कार्ड को ही ट्राई कीजिएगा
मोस्टली आपका वीजा ही वर्क करेगा कभी-कभी
आपका मास्टर कार्ड में भी वर्क कर जाए या
शायद कर जाए बट वीजा तो आपका 100% काम
करेगा तो आप वीजा कार्ड ही यूज कि रुपए
कार्ड होगा तो आपका नहीं चलेगा डेबिट
कार्ड की मैं बात कर रहा हूं ठीक है ओके
गट
इट हां ₹ वाला चलेगा बिल्कुल चलेगा ₹
चलेगा इस पे आ जाइएगा क्रिएट फ्री अकाउंट
पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा यहां पे क्रिएट फ्री
अकाउंट पे करके यहां पे आपको एक ईमेल
एड्रेस ऐड करना पड़ेगा ठीक है तो आप अपना
रियल ईमेल एड्रेस डालिए याद रखिए गाइस आप
अपना टेंपररी कोई भी टेंपररी ईमेल आईडी
यूज मत कीजिएगा आई थिंक शायद ये लेगा भी
नहीं बट स्टिल आप अपना रियल ईमेल आईडी यूज
कीजिएगा क्योंकि फर्द कोई कम्युनिकेशन
करनी होगी तो आप उसी ईमेल आई आईडी से
एडब्ल्यू सपोर्ट से बात कर सकते हैं अगर
किसी का बिल भी आ जाता है बाय चांस तो आप
ऐसे बोल के कि हम एक स्टूडेंट हैं हम इतना
अफोर्ड नहीं कर सकते बिल आप थोड़ा सा बच
भी सकते हैं बट अगर आपने पहले ही गलत कर
दिया होगा तो फिर दिक्कत आ जाएगी ठीक है
तो यहां पे वेरीफाई ईमेल एड्रेस पे क्लिक
कर देना है ईमेल आईडी डाल के
एंड वेरिफिकेशन कोड डाल देना है ठीक है
अपने ईमेल आईडी डालिए यहां पे वेरिफिकेशन
कोड आएगी आपकी ईमेल आईडी पे वो वेरिफिकेशन
कोड आपको एंटर कर देना है सो आई एम वेटिंग
फॉर द वेरिफिकेशन कोड तो मैं यहां पे आता
हूं याद खगा आप टेंपररी ईमेल आईडी यूज मत
कीजिएगा फंस जाएंगे मतलब आपको कभी फ्यूचर
में कोई दिक्कत आएगी ना तो ईडब्ल्यूएस की
सपोर्ट काफी अच्छी है आपको काफी अच्छा
सपोर्ट दे देती है अगर ज्यादा बिल आ जाता
है तो आप एक एज अ स्टूडेंट तो रियल में है
भी तो आपका वो बिल थोड़ा सा माफ हो जाएगा
मतलब वो छोड़ देते हैं ठीक है रूट का यहां
पे आ गया यहां पे रूट का अब यूजर पासवर्ड
मांग रहा है तो मैं यहां पर पासवर्ड दे
देता
हूं
इस तरीके से कर दीजिएगा कंटिन्यू कर
दीजिएगा ठीक है यहां पे ओके यह पासवर्ड
मैंने वैसे ही सिंपल सा डाल दिया था मैं
कोई और डाल देता
हूं यह डिटेक्ट भी करते हैं अगर कोई
पासवर्ड लीड है तो व पासवर्ड आप यूज नहीं
करेंगे ठीक है यह भी पासवर्ड लीड हो गया
यार क्या बात है
यार चलो एक और डाल देते
हैं यह भी पासवर्ड अजीब है चलो एक काम कर
लेते हैं कुछ कुछ भी डाल देते हैं अभी के
लिए चलिए तो यहां पे आपका यह सारा कुछ हो
जाएगा आपके अकाउंट क्रिएट हो आपके डिटेल्स
आ गए यहां पे अब यहां पे आ रहा है हाउ डू
यू वांट टू प्लान टू यूज द एडब्ल्यू एस तो
आप पर्सनल कर दीजिएगा बिजनेस मत कीजिएगा
पर्सनल कर दीजिएगा अब यहां पे कांटेक्ट के
लिए आपसे कैसे कांटेक्ट करना है आपका पूरा
नाम दे देंगे नितेश सिंह पूरा नाम दे
दीजिएगा यहां पे यहां पे फोन नंबर
मांगेंगे फोन नंबर दे दीजिए कोई सा भी फोन
नंबर आप दे दीजिए यहां पे अ मैं यहां प
इंडिया चूज कर लीजिए एंड यहां पे एक फोन
नंबर दे देना है ठीक है उसके बाद डिटेल
सेट कर देना है एंड कंटिन्यू वगैरह कर
लेना है उसके बाद जब आप कंटिन्यू वगैरह कर
लेंगे डिटेल सेट करके कंटिन्यू तो आपसे
कार्ड का पेमेंट मांगेगा मैं आपको इससे
ज्यादा मैं आपको सारे स्टेप्स बता रहा हूं
सिंपल ताकि आप वो कर पाए इसके बाद यह
बोलेगा कि कौन से कार्ड से तो चलिए यहां
पर नंबर के लिए भी मैं यहां पर नंबर
फिलहाल के लिए दे देता हूं कोई सा भी
एक नंबर फिलहाल के लिए कोई सा भी मैं दे
देता हूं
एक चलिए यहां पर कंट्री सेट कर देता हूं
मैं यहां पर रीजन इंडिया एंड यहां पर
एड्रेस देना है एड्रेस यहां पर देना ही
पड़ेगा तो दे देता हूं
मैं
ओके
यहां पे एड्रेस दे देते
हैं ओके पोस्टल कोड दे देते हैं ठीक है
एंड यहां पे अग्री कर दीजिएगा उसके बाद
कंटिन्यू कर लीजिएगा कंटिन्यू करेंगे तो
अब यहां पे आती है मेन आपकी चीज मेन स्टेप
यहां पे क्या है क्रेडिट कार्ड या डेबिट
कार्ड का यहां पे आपको डिटेल डालना है मंथ
एक्सपायरी डेट वगैरा डालना है कार्ड
होल्डर का नाम डालना है यहां पे आपका
एड्रेस यूज कर लेना है एंड पैन नंबर आपके
पास है तो पैन नंबर डाल दीजिएगा
दैट्ची कार्ड ऐड करेंगे तो यहां क्रेडिट
कार्ड आपको ऐड गलती से भी नहीं करना है
आपको वैसे बैंक के कार्ड जो रुपए हो या
मास्टर हो और वैसे बैंक के कार्ड जो
इंटरनेशनल ट्रांजैक्शन सपोर्ट करते हो और
डेबिट कार्ड हो जिसमें ज्यादा पैसे आप
नहीं रखते हो उसको डालिए यहां पे ₹ के
आसपास आपका कट होगा पहली बार जो आपका
ऑटोमेटिक रिफंड भी हो जाएगा वो हमेशा
केलिए नहीं होगा रिफंड हो जाएगा ठीक है तो
आराम से इसमें डालिए टेंशन फ्री होके उसके
बाद आपका अकाउंट क्रिएट हो जाएगा दैट्ची
आपका अकाउंट क्रिएट होके आ जाएगा एंड आपका
एडब्ल्यू का कंसोल ओपन हो उसके बाद आपको
एडब्ल्यू एस में लॉग इन करना होगा सिंपल
जैसे कि मैं यहां पे आया उसके बाद
एडब्ल्यूएसएटी कंसोल पे क्लिक कीजिएगा
साइन इन टू कंसोल जैसे ही आप साइन इन टू
कंसोल करेंगे यूजर नेम पासवर्ड मांगा
जाएगा यहां से और आप यहां पे अपना यूजर
नेम एंड पासवर्ड देंगे रूट यूजर की तरह ही
आप लॉग इन करेंगे आईएम यूजर अभी नहीं
करेंगे ये एक अलग चीज है आईएम यूजर क्रिएट
करना होता है कर सकते हैं आप बट अभी
फिलहाल क्योंकि आपने रूट बनाया तो आपका
रूट यूजर ईमेल आईडी जो आपने दी थी वो ईमेल
आईडी डाल दीजिएगा यहां पे एंड उसके बाद
आपका जो पासवर्ड था वो पासवर्ड आपको देना
है
यह पासवर्ड डालना है यह पासवर्ड यूजर नेम
डाल के आप लॉगिन करेंगे एंड लॉग इन करते
ही आपके पास कुछ इस तरह का एडब्ल्यू एस
मैनेजमेंट कंसोल ओपन होके आ जाएगा
दैट्ची है यहां पे रुपए अब ले रहे हैं ये
ठीक है अब ये रुपए ले रहे हैं पहले ये
रुपए नहीं ले रहे थे तो ये अब रुपए कार्ड
लेंगे पहले दे वेर नॉट एक्सेप्टिंग रुपए
कार्ड तो वीजा मास्टर कार्ड एमए और रुपए
ये चारों ले रहे हैं तो आपके पास रुपए भी
है तो भी आपका चल जाएगा ठीक है पहले ये
रुपए कार्ड एक्सेप्ट नहीं करते थे अब शायद
गवर्नमेंट के तरफ से जो वो एक चली हुई है
रुपए कार्ड के लिए तो उसके वजह से यह
एक्सेप्ट कर रहे हैं राइट एंड यहां पे
देखो वी मे टेंपरली होल्ड अप टू डलर ड एज
और एन इक्विवेलेंट अमाउंट इन लोकल करेंसी
एस अ पेंडिंग ट्रांजैक्शन फॉर थ्री टू
फाइव डेज टू वेरीफाई योर आइडेंटिटी तो यह
मतलब वही थोड़े से अमाउंट जो है वो होल्ड
पर रखेंगे बस बात खत्म बाकी और कुछ नहीं
ताकि ये डेबिट कार्ड वैलिड है उससे ये
थोड़ा सा उसको टेस्ट कर लेंगे बस और कुछ
नहीं वेरीफाई कर लेंगे ट्स इट तो टेंशन
नहीं लेना आपको फिर से वो पैसा वापस आ
जाएगा ठीक
है
ओके
गॉट इट
एवरीवन यहां पर सब लोगों का कार्ड यहां पे
आ रहा है यहां पे इतना सब लोगों ने किया
है अकाउंट क्रिएट हुआ या इतने तक पहुंच गए
या डेबिट कार्ड से यूज उनका किसी ने अभी
किया है करेंटली किसी ने अभी जस्ट यहां पर
डेबिट कार्ड डाल के किसी ने अभी जस्ट
बनाया अकाउंट मुझे बता
दीजिए मुझे बता दीजिए किसी ने अभी किया है
बनाया
है ओके गर्वित
मैं ओके ठीक है गर्वित मैंने तुम्हें
मॉडरेटर बना दिया है गर्वित एक बार देख लो
मॉडरेटर बना दिया है तो तुम किसी के भी
चैट पर क्लिक करके ऐसे उनको टाइम आउट में
डाल सकते हो जो स्पैम करेंगे ना उनको टाइम
आउट के लिए 30 30 मिनट या 24 घंटे के लिए
टाइम आउट डाल द ज्यादा करे तो 24 घंटे और
थोड़ी बहुत करें तो 30 मिनट के लिए कर
देना उनको तुम्हे जो भी लगे ठीक है गॉट इट
कार्ड नहीं है तो कुछ नहीं हो सकता है
ऑर्बिट एक्स वाई
जड कोई भी आप लोग प्लीज मैसेज कीजिए तो
स्पैम मत कीजिए अदर वाइज आपको टाइम आउट
में डालना पड़ेगा मजबूरी है मैं चाहता
नहीं हूं टाइम आउट में डालना फिर आप वो
इंटरेक्ट नहीं कर पाएंगे प्लीज ठीक है सो
मैंने गर्वित को बना दिया है एंड आई होप
कि गर्वित हैंडल इट
राइट ओके
चलिए सो किसी का भी बना किसी का भी
बना ओके लक लाइक मोहम्मद आपका बन चुका है
लाइक ठीक है अ शैलेश ठीक है अभी किसी-किसी
का बना कि नहीं पहले बताइए जल्दी बनाइए
जल्दी बता दीजिए फटाफट फिर हम आगे प्रोसीड
करते हैं लेट मी
नो टेंप मेल मत यूज करो यार कितनी बार
बोला हे भगवान टेंप मेल यूज नहीं करना है
रियल ईमेल आईडी यूज करो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है ताकि फर्द तुम कम्युनिकेशन कर पाओगे उस
रियल ईमेल आईडी से एडब्ल्यू एस से टेंप
मेल यूज करोगे वह नहीं देंगे कोई तुम्हारे
सपोर्ट का आंसर कोई भी क्वेश्चन का आंसर
याद
रखो ठीक है हां हां कोई से भी यूज कर सकते
हो नहीं नहीं नहीं लेगा टेंपररी कार्ड यूज
नहीं होगा सारे ब्लॉक कर दिए हैं लगभग
एडब्ल्यू एस ने रियल कार्ड यूज
करो मेरा भी बना न्यू अकाउंट से बनाया
बढ़िया देखो जब तक डेबिट कार्ड नहीं है
मैं बता रहा हूं आपको डेबिट कार्ड नहीं है
तो आप एडब्ल्यू एस हो डिजिटल ओसियन हो या
कोई सा भी क्लाउड प्लेटफार्म हो उसपे नहीं
कर सकते आप क्लाउड का सेटअप क्योंकि डेबिट
कार्ड की एक वेरिफिकेशन सब जगह मैंडेटरी
है वो चाहिए ही चाहिए प्लीज तो आपके पास
डेबिट कार्ड होना चाहिए आपके पास नहीं है
अपने पेरेंट ले लो या कोई जानकार का ले लो
क्योंकि उसमें से पैसे नहीं कटने वाले ठीक
है चलिए अब मैं आपको एक और तरीका बताऊंगा
कि पैसे ना कटे और उसको कैसे हम इसको
मैनेज कर सकते ईडब्ल्यूएस के अंदर ताकि
हमें अलर्ट मिलता जाए ताकि हमें पता चलता
जाए कि भैया पैसा कट रहा है या नहीं कट
रहा क्या हो रहा है यह सब पता चलता जाए
राइट तो यह भी मैं आपको अभी बताऊंगा टेंशन
आपको नहीं लेनी
है यह भी आपको बताया जाएगा बस थोड़ा वेट
कीजिए
चलिए ठीक है लेट मी सी ईमेल आईडी ये वाली
लॉगइन है कि नहीं हमारी अभी यस ईमेल आईडी
ये वाली है बढ़िया देखिए मैं आपको एक ऐसा
भी तरीका भी बताऊंगा जहां पे अगर आपका
एडब्ल्यू एस का मान लो एक ऐसा भी तरीका
बताऊंगा जहां पे अगर मान लो आपका एडब्ल्यू
एस का क्या हो रहा है एडब्ल्यू एस का बहुत
ज्यादा यूज हो रहा है या ज्यादा चार्जेस
लगने वाले होंगे तो आपको अलर्ट आ जाएगा
कैसे इस तरह का फ्री टियर का अलर्ट आएगा
इस तरीके से एडब्ल्यू एस फ्री टियर यूसेज
लिमिट अलर्ट एंड यहां पे बजट आपका जो है
यह बजट का अलर्ट आ गया है कि एक्सीडेड द
85 पर ऑफ द यूसेज लिमिट इ वन ऑफ वन और मोर
एड्स फ्री टेयर एलिजिबल सर्विसेस फॉर द
मंथ ऑफ जनवरी तो कौन सा तो ट का हमारा 750
घंटे का यूसेज लिमिट थोड़ा बढ़ गया है बस
मतलब 85 पर उसका यूज हो चुका है थोड़ा और
बचा हुआ है और उसमें से जब यूज हो जाएगा
तो आपके चार्जेस अकर करना स्टार्ट हो
जाएंगे इस तरह का अलर्ट आएगा या फिर आपको
कुछ इस तरह का भी अलर्ट आएगा रुको वयर इट
इज वयर इट इज
ये ये इस तरीके का यह भी एक उसी तरह का है
कि 85 पर वो हो गया है इसके अलावा आपके
पास एक और अलर्ट आएगा बजट का मैं वो भी
आपको बताऊंगा कैसे कैसे किस तरीके से
कन्फर करना है यह सारा कुछ आपको बताया
जाएगा राइट चलिए बढ़िया तो अब हमने अकाउंट
क्रिएट कर लिया आई होप कि काफी लोगों के
अकाउंट क्रिएट हो गए
होंगे बन गया बहुत बढ़िया मयंक बहुत
अच्छा ठीक है बहुत बढ़िया चलिए चलिए अगर
आपका ठीक है बहुत बढ़िया ओके अब यहां पे
आपने क्रिएट कर लिया आप जब लॉग इन कर
लेंगे तो लॉग इन करने के बाद यह पोर्टल
आपके सामने ओपन होके आ जाएगा अब इस पोर्टल
में आगे बढ़ने से हम क्लाउड सेटअप करने से
पहले एक बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट चीज देखेंगे जब
आप इस पे जाएंगे तो यहां पे आपको एक ऑप्शन
आएगा बिलिंग एंड कॉस्ट मैनेजमेंट का ठीक
है बिलिंग एंड कॉस्ट मैनेजमेंट इस पे आ
जाइएगा बिलिंग एंड कॉस्ट मैनेजमेंट जिनका
नहीं हुआ आप प्लीज बनाइए क्योंकि आपको एक
दिन का गैप मिलेगा टेंशन नहीं लेना है
आपको नेक्स्ट सेशन से पहले एक दिन का गैप
होगा ठीक है तो उस एक दिन के गैप
में आप लोग डेबिट कार्ड का इंतजाम कीजिएगा
वीजा मास्टर कार्ड रुपए कार्ड एंड वहां पे
आप क्रिएट कर लीजिएगा अकाउंट
दैट्ची जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी क्योंकि वो एकदम
क्लियर हो जाएगा सब कुछ दिमाग में बैठ
जाएगा ठीक है चलो अब देखो एडब्ल्यू एस
अकाउंट बनाते ही सबसे पहले आपको क्या करना
है आपको यहां पे आना है अ बिलिंग एंड
कंसोल कॉस्ट मैनेजमेंट में नीचे की तरफ
आना है यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आइएगा एंड
यहां पे आपको पे पेमेंट प्रेफरेंसेस के
नीचे बिलिंग प्रेफरेंसेस दिखेगा बिलिंग
प्रेफरेंसेस पे आ जाइएगा बिलिंग
प्रेफरेंसेस पे जब आप बिलिंग प्रेफरेंसेस
पे आएंगे तो आपको इनवॉइस डिलीवरी
प्रेफरेंस अलर्ट प्रेफरेंस इस तरह की दो
चीजें आपको दिखेंगी ठीक है अब देखो इनवॉइस
डिलीवरी प्रेफरेंस जो है इस पे एडिट पे
क्लिक मैं करता हूं यहां पे आपको टिक कर
देना होता है पीडीएफ इनवॉइस डिलीवर्ड बाय
ईमेल यानी कि ये आपको पीडीएफ में इनवॉइस
भेजेंगे जो भी आपका चार्जेज या जो भी होगा
आपको मंथली भेज दिया जाएगा एंड सबसे बड़ी
बात अलर्ट प्रेफरेंसेस आप अलर्ट
प्रेफरेंसेस प आएंगे एडिट पर क्लिक करेंगे
भैया तो यहां पे आपको इस पर टिक करना है
रिसीव एडब्ल्यू एस फ्री टियर अलर्ट्स यानी
जब भी कोई फ्री टियर में आपको जो जो
अ फैसिलिटी मिली है ना क्या मिलती है आपको
देखो एडब्ल्यू एस फ्री टियर मैं आपको
बताता हूं सबसे ज्यादा इसमें इंपॉर्टेंट
क्या है मैं बस वो बता देता हूं बाकी सब
आपको कोई ज्यादा रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है
फ्री टियर में आपको 1 साल तक एडब्ल्यू
फ्री मिलता है फ्री ट्रायल करने के लिए
ठीक है इसमें आपको क्या मिलता है गाइज 750
घंटे का
amazon2 मिलता है इलास्टिक क्लाउड
कंप्यूटिंग जिसका यूज हम करने वाले हैं s3
का भी 5gb का स्टोरेज मिलता है जिसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट हमें ज्यादा नहीं पड़ने वाली
है ज्यादा क्या ऑलमोस्ट नहीं पड़ने वाली
है तो हमारे लिए ये इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं है
हमारे लिए सबसे ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है 750
घंटे का ये ec2
amazon's मशीन चला सकते हैं या कोई भी
माइक्रो t3 माइक्रो ठीक है ना ऐसे इस तरह
के कुछ मतलब मशीन के नाम से इनके या जो
बोलो यार तुम एक एरिया का नाम बोलो व्हाट
एवर एक मशीन का नाम होता है तो ये मशीन के
नाम t2 t3 माइक्रो जो है ना इसमें कुछ
प्री डिफाइंड कॉन्फिन के मशीन आप यूज कर
सकते हैं कुछ स्पेसिफिक अ स्पीड या
प्रोसेसर वाले मशीन आप यूज कर सकते हैं तो
ये आपको 750 घंटे मिलते हैं ये सबसे बड़ी
बात है ठीक है बस ये चीज आपको ध्यान में
रखना है
चलिए अब हम इसको अगर इफेक्टिवली यूज यूज
करेंगे तो हमारे लिए बहुत अच्छा है बहुत
बढ़िया काम करने वाला है तो आपको अलर्ट
प्रेफरेंस में आ जाना है ठीक
है हां मैं आपको बताता हूं देखो देखो देखो
यार मैं आपको एडब्ल्यू एस पे ये अभी बता
रहा हूं ठीक है एडब्ल्यू पे आई एम लेटिंग
अ लेटिंग यू अ लेटिंग यू नो कि कैसे
एडब्ल्यू पे आपको क्लाउड सेटअप करना है
एडब्ल्यू का अल्टरनेटिव बहुत सारा है जैसे
डिजिटल ओसन आप इसका भी यूज कर सकते हो
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
सॉरी माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एजर आप इसका भी यूज कर
सकते हो एजर क्लाउड का एजर क्लाउड का यूज
कर सकते हो एस योर क्लाउड उसके बाद आप
यहां पर ग क्लाउड का भी यूज कर सकते हो
ठीक है आप इन इस पर भी बना सकते हो देर आर
मल्टीपल सर्विसेस एंड मैं एक बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग सर्विस भी
बताऊंगा और मैं आपको एक बहुत ही चीप
वीपीएस क्लाउड सर्विस बताऊंगा जो इन सबसे
सस्ता रहेगा एंड आप उसको ही यूज़ करेंगे
जब आप थोड़ा इंटरमीडिएट लेवल पे आ जाएंगे
जब आपको हर महीने उसकी प्लान लेनी पड़ेगी
बहुत सस्ता इतने सस्ते में कहीं नहीं
मिलेगा आपको वो मैं बताऊंगा लेकिन उसके वो
मैं बताऊंगा
whatsappwap.in देखेंगे अगर आपको देखना है
बता अगर आपको डिजिटल ओसन का भी जानना है
तो बता
दीजिए ओके ठीक है जिसको जो अच्छा लगे आप
यूज़ कर सकते हैं आपको एड अच्छा लगता है
google3 अलर्ट वाले पे क्लिक करके यहां पे
एक ईमेल आईडी डाल दीजिएगा जिस पे आपको
फ्री अलॉट की जो भी आपकी अलॉट होगी उसकी
अपडेट आपकी ईमेल जो है वो आ जाया करेगी
समझ में आ गया
दैट्ची बिलिंग प्रेफरेंसेस अब यहां पे ऊपर
जाना है यहां आना है बजेट्स पे ठीक है
बजेट्स पे आना है बजेट्स पे जब आप आओगे तो
यहां पे एक बजट क्रिएट करने का ऑप्शन आपको
मिलता है बजट क्रिएट करने का ठीक है तो
क्रिएट बजट पे आपको क्लिक करना है क्रिएट
बजट पे करने के बाद कोई टेंप्लेट यूज़
करना है या कस्टमाइज करना है आप टेंप्लेट
यूज कर लीजिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं तो यहां पे
टेंप्लेट में जीरो स्पेंड बजट मंथली कॉस्ट
बजट डेली सेविंग प्लान एंड डेली रिजर्वेशन
ये सारी चीजें हैं यहां पे हमें मंथली
कॉस्ट बजट सेलेक्ट करना है मंथली का कॉस्ट
बजट जब इसको सिलेक्ट करेंगे तो यहां पर
आपको बजट का नाम दे देना है जैसे
माय एडब्ल्यू एस बजट अब इससे होगा क्या आप
इस बजट को रख दीजिए $ पे सॉरी या 5 रख
लीजिए $ का मतलब अराउंड 8300 के आसपास हो
गया है
ना $ का मतलब हां 830 के आसपास हो जाता है
तो $ रख लीजिए इसका मतलब जैसे ही आपका एक
मंथ का यूज केस
$ से क्रॉस करने वाला होगा ठीक है जैसे ही
आपको अलर्ट आ जाएगा कि भैया आप $10 से
क्रॉस कर रहे हो अब देख लो ज्यादा हो रहा
है आपका ठीक है बस हो गया यहां ईमेल आईडी
डाल दीजिएगा जो ईमेल आईडी जिस पे आप रिसीव
करना चाहते हैं जो भी मतलब आप रिसीव करना
चाहते हैं ईमेल आईडी यहां पे वो ईमेल आईडी
यहां पे डाल दीजिएगा
दैट्ची कंपनी की ईमेल आईडी ये आपने डाल
दिया इसी पे आपको अलर्ट्स आ जाएंगी एंड ये
सारी चीज सेटअप ट अप करके जब देखो यू विल
बी नोटिफाइड व्हेन कब आपको नोटिफाई
नोटिफाइड होगा योर एक्चुअल स्पेंड रिचेज
85 पर जब 85 पर इसका हो जाएगा तब एक बार
दूसरी बार आपको कब होगा योर एक्चुअल
स्पेंड्स रिचेज 100% जब आपका 100% यानी
$10 एक $10 का 85 पर जब यूज होगा तब एक
$10 हो जाएगा तब एंड इफ य फोरकास्टेड
स्पेंड एक्सपेक्टेड टू रीच 100% और अगर
फोरकास्टेड अगर स्पेंड स्पेंड है मतलब आगे
का फ्यूचर का स्पेंड फोरकास्ट ये कर लेता
है पहले ही भविष्यवानी कर लेता है तब अगर
आपको ये तब भी आपको अलर्ट भेजेगा ठीक है
तीन-तीन टाइप के अलर्ट ये आपको भेजता हो
क्रिएट बजट पे यहां पे क्लिक कर देना है
सिंपल क्रिएट बजट पर क्लिक कर दीजिएगा
आपका बजट जो है वो क्रिएट हो जाएगा सिंपल
एंड बजट क्रिएट होके आपको कुछ इस तरह का
ही बजट का जब आप इस पे आएंगे बजट वाले पे
तो इस तरह की एक लिस्ट आ जाएगी एंड यहां
पे आपका दिख जाएगा यहां पे सारा डिटेल
चलिए ये हो गया अब यहां पे देख रहे हो
अमाउंट यूज अभी तक $10 में से 0.25 यूज
हुआ है कब का ये ये कब का दिखा रहा है ये
जनवरी का दिखा रहा है और फोरकास्ट है $
मतलब इसको लग रहा है कि मैं $ तक यूज
करूंगा अभी ठीक है आ तो अभी और भी ज्यादा
फोरकास्ट होगा ये है ना चलिए ये आपको दो
काम कर लेने है समझ में आ गया समझ में आ
गया एवरीवन गॉट आ रहा हूं भाई आ रहा हूं
क्लाउड
में ठीक है चलिए अब हम यहां पे सारा कुछ
कर चुके हैं अब यहां पे जब आप आएंगे फ्री
टियर वाले ऑप्शन पे तो आपको यहां पे सारी
चीजें सर्विसेस आपको दिखेंगी आपने फ्री
टियर के कौन-कौन से सर्विस का कितना यूज
किया है जैसे आपको यहां पे दिख रहा होगा
गाइ देखो मैंने इलास्टिक कंप्यूट क्लाउड
ec2
का e2 का देखो यहां
पे 100 मतलब यह देखो यूज मंथली फोरकास्टेड
देखो एमटीडी डी मंथ टू डेट एक्चुअल यूज
परसेंट 100% हो चुका है मेरा फोरकास्टेड
यूज जो है 310 पर का है मेरा ट का समझ
मतलब यूज हो चुका है ऑलरेडी यार ऑलरेडी
यूज हो चुका है ठीक है जैसे यहां पे भी है
ये देखो इलास्टिक क्लाउड कंप्यूटर का एक
यह वन व आर का ये लाइक 12 मंथ्स पार्ट का
दूसरा चीज है इलास्टिक आईपी का है ये ये
आपका जो है 1gb का जो है ये आपका लाइक
इलास्टिक जो अ स्टोरेज आपको मिलता है
बेसिकली वो स्टोरेज जो है ना ब्लॉक
स्टोरेज जिसको आप बोलते हैं वो ब्लॉक
स्टोरेज का है एंड ये आपका 750 घंटे का है
जिसमें से 750 घंटे में से मैंने 85 पर
यूज ऑलमोस्ट कर लिया है थोड़े बहुत बाकी
भी है अभी और यहां पे 263 पर का आपको
फोरकास्टेड यूज मतलब फ्यूचर का यूज यूज
केस बता रहा है कि फ्यूचर में आप इतना
परसेंट यूज कर सकते हैं ये थोड़ा आपके यूज
केसेस पे ना ट्रैक करता है ये दिमाग लगा
देता है कि इतना आप यूज कर सकते हैं अब
बाकी चीजें मैं ज्यादा यूज नहीं करता आप
देख रहे होंगे कि अ
ये स्टोरेज बहुत ज्यादा यूज़ नहीं हुआ है
बाकी सर्विसेस बहुत कम यूज हुई है मेनली
e2 यूज होती है आपकी एंड आपका जो बैंडविथ
है वो यूज होता है मेनली ठीक है और ज्यादा
कुछ यूज होती नहीं है यहां पे चलिए ये
आपका हो गया बिल्स पे आप आएंगे तो यहां पे
आपको बिल्स दिख जाएंगे जब आप बिल्स पे
आएंगे गाइस तो यहां पे आपका बिल दिखेगा कि
आपने आपकी क्या बिलिंग रही है क्या-क्या
क्या आपने बिल पे किया है तो अगर आप
देखेंगे यहां पे जो जनवरी का भी बिल जनरेट
नहीं हुआ है मैं यहां पे दिसंबर 2023 में
चलता हूं तो यहां पे बिल एक जनरेट हुई है
इश्यूड यहां पे पेमेंट इंफॉर्मेशन पे
क्लिक करेंगे तो
amazon2 हुआ है इनवॉइस आईडी है इस पे
क्लिक करूंगा इनवॉइस डाउनलोड हो जाएगी एंड
यहां पे आपको लिखा हुआ दिख रहा होगा वेव्ड
जब वेव्ड लिखा आ रहा है ना मतलब हट गया
छोड़ दिया इन्होंने ऐसा नहीं है कुछ वेव
नहीं किया इन्होंने इन्होंने पैसे कट किए
हैं कहां से कट किए हैं वो भी मैं बताता
हूं फिलहाल बिल्स चलता हूं मैं यहां
पे लेट्स गो टू
द यहां
पे बिल्स पे ठीक है अब मैं आपको दिखाता
हूं कैसे यहां पे कट किया है ये जो है ना
बेसिकली मेरी बिलिंग का देखिए अभी हिसाब
किताब आपको मैं यहां पे हिसाब किताब
दिखाऊंगा तो आपका दिमाग घूम जाएगा यहां पे
यह देखिए यहां पे मैं होम पे चलता हूं
यहां पे बिलिंग कंसोल का एंड यहां देखो
लास्ट मंथ का मेरा जो टोटल कॉस्ट आया था
$27 का हमारा बिल आया हुआ था बट आपने देखा
होगा कि जीरो पेमेंट था वहां पे वो उसका
रीजन है मैं आपको बता देता हूं यहां पे
$27 का पेमेंट लास्ट आया हुआ था ठीक है
एंड अभी का जो है लाइक अभी तक का बहुत कम
यूज हुआ है अभी आने वाले टाइम में हो
जाएगा बट यह बिल क्यों माफ हो गया भाई
क्यों खत्म हो गया इसका रीजन यह है कि
क्रेडिट्स में जब मैं जाऊंगा ना क्रेडिट्स
में तो आपको मैं दिखा देता हूं यहां पे
एडब्ल्यू एस के तरफ से एडब्ल्यू एस के तरफ
से भैया मुझे कुछ क्रेडिट्स मिले
थे $300 के आसपास का $1000 मुझे मिले थे ए
डब्स का यूज करने का और $350 जो मिले थे
एडब्ल्यू एस का फाउंडर्स डेवलपर सपोर्ट
मिला था इसमें मुझे इसलिए मिले थे क्योंकि
मेरा जो अकाउंट था मैंने अप्लाई किया था
एडब्ल्यू एस का एक्टिव स्टार्टर स्टार्टअप
जो है ना एक्ट एक्टिवेट एक प्रोग्राम है
एडब्ल्यूएल
एस एक्टिवेट एडब्ल्यू एस एक्टिवेट जो है
ये एक स्टार्टअप के लिए प्लान होता है
जिसमें अगर आपका स्टार्टअप आपकी कंपनी
क्वालीफाई कर जाती है आपको अप्लाई करना
होता है तो आपको $100 तक यानी 00 नहीं
नहीं वैसे तो $ लाख डल तक देते हैं बट
मेरे को $100 जो है अप्रूवल आया था 00
मुझे मिले थे तो इसी 00 में से ये कट होते
रहते हैं मतलब जो भी अमाउंट डिडक्ट होता
है वो डिडक्ट होते रहते हैं ये एक फायदा
हो गया तो इसलिए अभी मुझे जो भी अमाउंट आ
भी रहे हैं क्योंकि हमारा और भी अभी बहुत
सारा काम चलता है सिर्फ मैं ये वाला चीज
नहीं करता और भी कंपनी के बहुत सारे
प्रोजेक्ट हैं वो चल रहे हैं बहुत सारी एक
कुछ टूल्स हम डेवलप कर रहे हैं वो टूल्स
इसी पे हमारे डेवलप हो रहे हैं एक पोर्टल
डेवलप हम कर रहे हैं टोटल सीटीएफ पोर्टल
हमारा खुद का सीटीएफ ग्राउंड हम डेवलप कर
रहे हैं वो भी इसी पे चल रहा है सब कुछ
इसी पे चल रहा है तो इसलिए ये थोड़ा बहुत
चार्जिंग वगैरह जो है ये आ जाती है तो
इसमें से देख रहे हैं आप कि इतने अमाउंट
रिमेनिंग है अभी 1200 कुछ इतने डॉलर जो है
वो यूज हो चुके हैं समझ में आ रहा
है गॉट इट तो ये आपको नहीं मिलेगा अगर
आपका स्टार्टअप है कोई तो आप अप्लाई कर
सकते हैं देन आपको मिलने का चांसेस है बट
आपका इंडिविजुअल के तौर प आपको ये क्रेडिट
नहीं मिलेगा ठीक है आपको वो 750 घंटे वाली
फ्री मिल जाएगी ठीक है चलिए यहां तक सबका
क्लियर हो गया मुझे बता दीजिए देख रहे हो
ना मजे रहे हैं यहां तक सबका
क्लियर एवरीवन क्लियर यहां
तक बता दीजिए जल्दी से चलिए ओके तो यह तो
काम हो गया अब यहां से हम निकल जाते हैं
एडब्ल्यू एस के वापस से एडब्ल्यू एस के
होम पेज प आ जाते हैं यहां
पे यस यस यस करेक्ट
करेक्ट बिल्कुल सही शांके बिल्कुल
क्लियर हो गया अब हम आते हैं अपने मेन
चीजों पे हम अपनी मेन चीजों पे आते हैं
जिसका इंतजार आप सबको था एंड जहां पे हम
हंट करना स्टार्ट करेंगे अ क्लाउड में ठीक
है बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाला है अभी
ध्यान दीजिएगा सभी लोग बहुत कम प्रेजेंस
है आज लाइव में आई डोंट नो क्यों इतना कम
प्रेजेंस है आज के सेशन में तो आपको होना
चाहिए था यार आज का सेशन बहुत-बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट सेशन था बहुत ज्यादा लाइव में
ही मजा आएगा
आपको चलिए तो अब हम यहां पे आ चुके हैं
नाउ व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू यूज इज टू आपको
क्या करना है सर्विसेस पे क्लिक करना है
और यहां आपको ईटू दिख जाएगा वर्चुअल
सर्वर्स इन द क्लाउड वीपीएस वर्चुअल
प्राइवेट सर्वर्स वर्चुअल सर्वर्स क्लाउड
मशीन ये वाला तो e2 को हम यूज करने वाले
हैं तो आपको करना क्या है सिंपली ऑल
सर्विसेस पे आके आप यहां पे सर्च भी कर
सकते हैं ec2 इलास्टिक क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग
इसका फुल फॉर्म होता है तो ट ये आ गया इस
पे आपको क्लिक कर देना है जैसे ही आप
क्लिक करेंगे भैया इस तरह का कुछ आपके
सामने जो है वो पोर्टल ओपन होके आ जाएगा
ठीक है अब इसके लेफ्ट साइड में ये जो
मेन्यूस है ये बहुत सारे मेन्यूस हैं
इलास्टिक आईपी सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप्स की
पेयर्स लोड बैलेंसर्स ये सब चीजें क्लाउड
कंप्यूटिंग का पार्ट है एंड हमारा जो
डीसीएसपी का लाइव ट्रेनिंग चलता है सिक्स
मंथ्स का उसमें ये सारी चीजें कवर्ड होती
है बहुत डिटेल में ठीक है बट अभी हम इस पे
नहीं जा रहे हैं क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग पे अभी
वी आर नॉट गोइंग ऑन क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग अभी
हमें बग बाउंट करनी है तो हम फिलहाल ec2
को ध्यान में रखते हुए कर रहे हैं अब e2
का मतलब क्या होता है इलास्टिक क्लाउड
कंप्यूटिंग का मतलब ये एक
amazon-in को हम क्लाउड में इंस्टॉल
करेंगे ठीक है तो अब कैसे करना है चलिए
देखिए यस चलिए अब य अब यहां पे आपको दिख
रहा होगा इंस्टेंसस इंस्टेंसस रनिंग यहां
पे मान लो दिख रहा है यह वही है क्लाउड
में जो हम इंस्टेंस लॉन्च करते हैं ना यह
हम इंस्टेंस लॉन्च करने वाले हैं यहां पे
एंड इंस्टेंस का मतलब यही है कि हम एक
मशीन को इंस्टॉल करके स्टार्ट करने वाले
हैं हम अपने यूज केस के लिए इसको हम
इंस्टेंस बोलते हैं सिंपल इंस्टेंस देख के
घबराना नहीं है अरे इंस्टेंस क्या हो गया
अभी तो कुछ और देख रहे थे इंस्टेंस अरे
भाई इंस्टेंस का मतलब मशीन है ठीक है यहां
पे हो बहुत बढ़िया ट्रेनिंग है आपकी सर
प्लीज से पूरा कंप्लीट करना बाय द वे क्या
आप लकी को जानते हो जी हां लकी इज आल्सो अ
पार्ट ऑफ डेनिक्स हमारे टीम का ही पार्ट
है एंड थैंक यू सो मच दीज है वी विल
कंटिन्यू एंड कंप्लीट दिस ट्रेनिंग डोंट
वरी अबाउट दैट ठीक है
सो लकी इज अ पार्ट ऑफ डिफर
निक्स
चलिए धन्यवाद डीजे भाई सुपर चैट के लिए
चलिए
ओके अब यहां पे आ जाते हैं एंड यहां पे अब
इंस्टेंसस पर क्लिक करेंगे इसका मतलब क्या
है ना मशीन कौन-कौन से चल रहे हैं क्लाउड
में कौन-कौन से मशीन चल रहे हैं बस
इंस्टेंस का मतलब यही समझिए रनिंग वाले पे
मैं क्लिक करके कैंसिल करता हूं देखिए
यहां पे 1 दोती च चार मशीनस यहां पे चल
रही है बट अभी फिलहाल के लिए स्टॉप्ड है
क्योंकि हम थोड़े बजट फ्रेंडली काम करते
हैं स्टॉप कर कर के चलाते हैं काम जब
पड़ता है तब हिसाब किताब देखते हैं ये
सारी चीज देखते हैं तो यहां पे आप देखें
ऑटोमेशन टारगेट टीएमपी टेंप सर्वर डीबी ये
सारे कुछ मशीनस है जो हम यूज कर रहे हैं
यहां पे आपको खुद का एक इंस्टेंस लच करना
है भैया खुद का और उसी में हम काली को
इंस्टॉल करने वाले हैं तो जल्दी से अब
देखते हैं कैसे वापस इसी पे आ जाते
हैं और भी कर देंगे अगर आप बोले तो अरे
नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं धन्यवाद दीजिए आप
क्या करते हो स्टूडेंट हो प्रोफेशनल हो
पहले ये बताओ
चलिए
[संगीत]
अ बहुत कुछ रह सकते हैं बिल्कुल रह सकते
हैं बिल्कुल रह सकते हैं बिल्कुल चलिए तो
ओके देन अब हमें लंच करना है अपना
इंस्टेंस कैसे लंच करना है भैया यहां पर
लच इंस्टेंस पर आपको क्लिक कर देना है
सिंपल सा लच इंस्टेंस पर क्लिक करेंगे इस
तरह का पोर्टल ओपन हो जाएगा यहीं से हमारी
शुरू होती है मशीन क्रिएट करने की स्टेप्स
अब इस पर ध्यान से एकदम ध्यान दीजिएगा नेम
आपको देना है कोई भी नेम दे दीजिए तो मैं
यहां पर दे देता हूं माई
काली माई काली इस तरीके से मैं नाम दे
देता हूं माई काली ठीक है मशीन का नाम
मैंने दे दिया कुछ भी दे सकते हो और यहां
पे जो है अब है यहां पे एमआई एमआई इनको
बोलते हैं ये सारे जो हैं
amazon2 डाउनलोड करते हो कोई काली का
डाउनलोड कर लिया वि का डाउनलोड कर उसको
इंस्टॉल कर लिया v एवे में या डायरेक्ट
मशीन में वैसे ही
amazonaws.com आप देख सकते हैं क्विक
क्विक स्टार्ट एमआई में 47 है लिस्ट में
माय ए 2 है ठीक है एड मार्केट प्लेस पे
8836 एआज हैं कम्युनिटी एआई 500 हैं यानी
कि आप देखो जैसे यह एक
aws.com r हैट चला सकते हैं आप नस चला
सकते हैं नटू चला सकते हैं माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
चला सकते हैं ऐसे बहुत सारे ऑपरेटिंग
डेवियन डेवियन को भी आप स्पेसिफिकली इफ यू
वांट टू रन डेवियन जिस पे बेस्ड है काली
यवन टू ये सब उसको चला सकते
हैं यवन टू के अलग-अलग
विज के अलग-अलग वर्जंस है सारी चीजें आपको
यहां पे मिल रही है ठीक है अब मुझे क्या
चाहिए भैया मुझे चाहिए यहां पे काली चलाना
है बट काली के लिए मैं यहां पे सर्च
करूंगा काली बस काली सर्च करके एंटर
करूंगा यहां पे यहां पे आपको काली जब सर्च
करेंगे लिखेगा नो रिजल्ट्स वेर फाउंड फॉर
काली इन क्विक स्टार्ट एमआई क्योंकि हमने
क्विक स्टार्ट पे क्लिक किया है हम आएंगे
कहां पे एडब्ल्यू मार्केट प्लेस पे जब इस
पे आएंगे तो आपको यहां पे काली की एक मशीन
दिखेगी यहां पे वर्जन काली lx2
23.4 ठीक है
2023 4 अब हमें यही यूज़ करना है आपको और
भी बहुत सारे यहां पे दिखेंगे काली के
अलग-अलग चीजें बट आपका एक काली जो
इंस्टेंस है मशीन है यह वाला इसको हम यूज
करने वाले हैं कैसे इसको सेलेक्ट कर लेना
है सेलेक्ट करते ही आपको यहां कुछ डिटेल्स
आएंगी इस डिटेल को जरूर पढ़िए टिपिकल टोटल
प्राइसिंग आप पढ़ लीजिएगा देख लीजिए 0.04
6 पर आर ठीक है जब आप t2 मीडियम को होस्ट
करेंगे t2 मीडियम वाला होस्ट करेंगे यूएस
ईस्ट वन में तब आपका क्या आएगा भैया ये
0.06 पर आर का लगभग चार्ज आएगा ली 20 23.4
इसमें यूज हो रही है ठीक है प्रोडक्ट
डिटेल्स पे आप आएंगे तो सी डिटेल्स आपको आ
जाएगी प्राइसिंग आपको यहां पर अगेन वही
चीज प्राइसिंग आ जाएगी आपकी यूसेज के बारे
में डिटेल्स वगैरह सपोर्ट वगैरह आ जाएगा
तो यह बहुत वैसे कम होता है 0.46 पर आर का
मतलब है ना देख लीजिए
आप डॉलर टू आनर में आते हैं एंड यहां पे
0.04 6 पर आर 82 पैसे लगभग ार एक घंटे का
आपको आ रहा है ठीक है लगभग चार ₹ एक घंटे
का ठीक है बस और कुछ नहीं 10 घंटे भी
चलाते हैं तो लगभग 0 के आसपास कॉस्टिंग
आती है बट इसके अलावा और भी दूसरे कस्टस
होते हैं आपके ईटू के इंस्टेंस के टाइमिंग
की कॉस्ट हो जाती है और भी आप कंसल रीजन
यूज कर रहे हैं उसकी कॉस्टिंग अलग हो जाती
है आपकी ठीक है एंड उसके बाद t2 मीडियम इन
मीडियम यूज कर रहे हैं माइक्रो यूज कर रहे
हैं कौनसा यूज करें उसके ऊपर भी आ जाती है
ठीक
है सारी चीजें कर सकते हैं ग्रेट चलिए दज
ए मैंने लकी से वेब पन टेस्टिंग की
ट्रेनिंग ली है ग्रेट दीजे यू मस्ट हैव
गॉट सम इंटरेस्ट ि ट्रेनिंग फ्रॉम हिम
राइट ही अ वेरी गुड ट्रेनर डीजे ट्स
ग्रेट चलिए तो अब यहां
पे एंड भाई यह सुपर चैट अब मत करो यार
कितना करोगे सुपर चैट डीजे भाई एक बंदा
सुपर चैट कितनी करोगे रुक जाओ जाने दो
रहने दो अब यहां प कर दिया आप कंटिन्यू पर
क्लिक कर दीजिएगा ठीक है यहां पर अब
कंटिन्यू पर जैसे ही आप क्लिक करोगे आपका
यहां पर काली मशीन वो जो है सेलेक्ट हो
जाएगा ठीक है यहां पे आपको दिख रहा होगा
देखो यहां पे यहां पे देखो इसमें आपका
ईडब्ल्यूएस जो आपका फ्री टियर है ना फ्री
टियर फ्री टियर वाला अलर्ट वो तो आपका यूज
हो रहा है फ्री टियर वाला ठीक है भैया बट
इस चीज में क्योंकि ये काली का फ्री टियर
एलिजिबल आप नीचे आओगे ना मैं आपको दिखाता
हूं अभी क्या अभी किस तरीके से आपकी चा
किस तरीके से आपकी चार्ज आएगी कि नहीं
आएगी मैं आपको बता रहा हूं ठीक है यहां पे
काली का स्नैपशॉट हमने डाल लिया यहां पे
यहां पे आप चाहे अगर इफ यू वांट तो आप
इसके फ्री जैसे आप ब्राउज मोर पर चलते हैं
यहां पे यहां पर चलते हैं एड मार्केट
प्लेस प आते हैं एंड यहां पे आप डेवियन
सिलेक्ट करेंगे डेवियन तो
आपको यहां से डायरेक्टली यहां पर आ जाते
हैं ब्राउज मोर एमआई इस पर आ जाते हैं तो
आपको यहां पे एक डेवियन मिलेगा ये डेवियन
ये फ्री टियर एलिजिबल है याद रखिएगा तो
इसमें ये फ्री टियर एलिजिबल काम करेगा
आपका बिल्कुल परफेक्टली काम करेगा इसमें
कोई चाज नहीं इसमें भी आप काली की तरह ही
सारा कुछ कर पाएंगे जो भी आप करना चाहते
हैं काली की तरह डेवियन में भी आप कर
पाएंगे ठीक है बस ज्यादा कुछ टेंशन आपको
लेने की जरूरत नहीं है तो आप ये भी कर
सकते हैं या तो आप डायरेक्टली काली भी यूज
कर सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं आएगी
फिलहाल हमारा काली हम यूज़ कर रहे हैं
डायरेक्टली यहां पे काली याद रखिएगा गाइ
डेबिट कार्ड डेबिट कार्ड चार्ज अगर आएंगे
भी तो मेल पे आप बात करके एंड उनसे व
चार्ज को बोल के कि स्टूडेंट हूं मैं एंड
इतना नहीं अफोर्ड कर सकता मैं टेस्ट कर
रहा था ओनली अलग-अलग चीजों को इसलिए लिए
हमें चार्ज आ गया होगा ठीक है तो यहां पे
काली हमने इंस्टॉल काली हमने डाल लिया
यहां पे सेलेक्ट कर लिया अब नीचे आएंगे अब
यहां पे आएगा इंस्टेंस टाइप भैया इंस्टेंस
टाइप कौन सा आपको यूज करना है तो यहां पे
पहले से t2 मीडियम सिलेक्टेड है ठीक है
बढ़िया नीचे आइएगा तो t2 मीडियम जो है
फ्री टियर एलिजिबल नहीं है फ्री टियर के
लिए t2 माइक्रो ही आपको यूज करना पड़ेगा
और इसमें आपको क्या मिलता है वन वर्चुअल
सीपीयू एक जीब का मेमोरी ठीक है यह दोनों
चीज़ें यह कॉन्फ़िगरेशन आपको इसमें मिल
जाती है यह मोर दन सफिशिएंट है स्टार्ट
करने के लिए बट अगर आप चाहें तो दूसरा कर
सकते हैं बट उसमें आपको चार्जेस देने
पड़ेंगे इसमें जो फ्री टियर एलिजिबल है वह
एक ही है t2 माइक्रो t2 स्मॉल या t2
मीडियम भी आप करेंगे तो आपको फिर वहां पे
ज्यादा चार्ज देना पड़ेगा तो यहां पे मैं
t2 स्मल भी यूज़ कर सकता हूं t2 माइक्रो
भी यूज़ कर सकता हूं फिलहाल के लिए मैं t2
स्मल यूज़ करता हूं आपको मैं रिकमेंड
करूंगा गो फॉर t2 माइक्रो क्योंकि यह फ्री
टियर एलिजिबल है तो आपके फ्री टर में
इंक्लूड हो जाएगा यह वाला इंस्टेंस टाइप
समझ में आ गया गया बस तो आप t2 माइक्रो के
लिए जाइएगा मैं t2 स्मॉल कर ले रहा हूं
क्योंकि थोड़ा बहुत मेरा चार्ज आएगा भी तो
मुझे कोई ज्यादा फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा क्रेडिट
से वो डिडक्ट हो जाएगा तो फिलहाल के लिए
आपको ये t2 स्मॉल आई एम यूजिंग एक वर्चुअल
सीपीयू एंड 2gb का मेमोरी मिल रहा है तो
बढ़िया रहेगा चलिए ये आ
गए अब यहां पे आने के बाद एक की पेयर का
ऑप्शन है इसमें आपको की पेयर बनानी पड़ती
है ताकि जब आप कनेक्ट करें इस मशीन से तो
आप इसी की पेयर से कनेक्ट करेंगे एसएसए जब
आप करेंगे तो इसी की पेयर से आप करेंगे
याद रखिएगा इसके बिना आप नहीं कर पाएंगे
भैया यू कैन नॉट डू विदाउट दिस ठीक है
चलिए
तो
ओके अब की पेयर में यहां पे क्रिएट न्यू
की पेयर पे क्लिक कीजिएगा यहां पे कर
दीजिएगा कुछ भी की पेयर तो यहां पे कर
दीजिएगा अ काली अ लिनिक्स मैंने डाल दिया
आरएसएस सेलेक्ट करके रखिएगा जो इंक्रिप्शन
टाइप है वो आरएस रहने दीजिएगा एंड
प्राइवेट की फाइल जो है पीएम फॉर्मेट ही
रहने दीजिएगा जिसका कि आप ओपन एसएसए के
थ्रू यूज़ करना चाहते जैसे एसएसए कमांड के
थ्रू यूज करना चाहते हैं तो पीएम पुटी के
साथ यूज करना चाहते हैं पुटी नाम की एक
सॉफ्टवेयर आती है पटी पटी ये
पुटी ये पुटी नाम की एक सॉफ्टवेयर आती है
अगर आपको इससे कनेक्ट करना है इससे आप
ग्राफिकली भी कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं पुटी से
मतलब कमांड लाइन ग्राफिक जो भी करना है
कमांड लाइन से आप कनेक्ट करेंगे पुटी में
डाल के तो इसके लिए आपको पीपी के फाइल
चाहिए तो हम पीएम कर रहे हैं हम एसएसएस का
यूज करने वाले हैं और कुछ भी नहीं ये करके
क्रिएट की पेयर पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा जैसे
ही क्रिएट करिएगा यहां कीपर की फाइल
डाउनलोड हो जाएगी k
linux.org पीएस एसटीटीपी भी आप कर दीजिए
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है बट अलाउ एसस एच ये
जरूर से ऑन रहना चाहिए अब यह एनी वेयर
कहां से कहीं से भी एसएसए अलाउड हो आप यह
रख सकते हैं अभी के लिए बट जब आप
सिक्योरिटी ओरिएंटेड सेटिंग्स करेंगे तो
आप एक कस्टम आईपी खुद का एक आईपी डाल
दीजिएगा जो आपकी खुद की आईपी होगी वह आईपी
डाल दीजिएगा कि यहां से ही एसएसए अलाउड
होगा तो उसी पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस मतलब आईपी
से आपका ये एसएस कनेक्शन बनेगा बाकी किसी
से नहीं बनेगा फिलहाल के लिए एनी वेयर कर
देता हूं मैं एंड एनी वेयर करके हम आगे
बढ़ते हैं ठीक है
चलिए अब यहां पे देख सकते हैं यहां पे कि
अब कितने जीब की स्टोरेज आपको चाहिए तो
फ्री टियर में 30gb तक का ईवीएस स्टोरेज
आपको मिल सकता है 30gb तक का आप ले सकते
हैं तो चलिए मैं यहां पे 30gb तो नहीं
25gb ले लेता हूं 25gb का स्टोरेज मैं ले
लेता हूं 25gb वुड बी सफिशिएंट मेरे ख्याल
से 30gb भी कर सकते हैं एंड बाकी सारी
चीजें सेम रहने दीजिएगा बाकी आपको कुछ भी
नहीं करना है ठीक है तो यहां पे आपको समरी
दिख जाएगी राइट साइड में कि आपका काली l
t2 स्मल t2 स्मॉल थाका हां t2 स्मल
सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप बन गई है 25gb की
स्टोरेज मिल गई है आपकी एंड लॉन्च
इंस्टेंस पे आपको क्लिक कर देना है
दैट्ची इंस्टेंस पर क्लिक करेंगे हमारा
इंस्टेंस जो है वो स्टार्ट होना हो जाएगा
स्टार्ट होना शुरू हो जाएगा एंड आपका
इंस्टेंस थोड़ी देर में जो है वो लॉन्च हो
जाएगा सक्सेसफुली इनिशिएटिव
आपको दिखेगा माई काली जो पेंडिंग दिखेगा
अभी यहां पे दिख रहा है आपको
पेंडिंग अब आपको थोड़ा इंतजार करना है अब
यहां पे
मैं हां अब मैं यहां पे थोड़ा वेट करूंगा
यह रिफ्रेश का बटन है रिफ्रेश पे क्लिक
कीजिएगा रिफ्रेश होता रहेगा यहां पे ये
पेंडिंग आ रहा है अभी भी चलिए वेट कीजिए
थोड़ा सा अभी ये पेंडिंग हो रहा है अभी जब
तक ये पेंडिंग रहेगा तब तक आपको कुछ नहीं
करना है आपको ऐसे ही रहना है जब तक आप
आपको आईपी ना मिल जाए यहां पे जब आप इधर
राइट साइड में आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको एक
आईपी मिल तो गई है पब्लिक आईपी बट अभी
आपको वेट करना है जब तक यह फुली रेडी ना
हो जाए अब यह रनिंग पे आ गया रनिंग आ गया
रनिंग बट स्टिल अभी आपको यहां फिर से
रिफ्रेश करिए अभी भी आपको कुछ नहीं करना
है स्टेटस चेक में इनिशियल इजिंग लिख रहा
है आपको वेट करना है जब तक यह पास ना हो
जाए तो जब तक यह पास ना हो जाए आपको वेट
करना है रनिंग तो हो गया बट आपको अभी भी
वेट करना है यू हैव टू वेट ठीक
है
हां आपके फिजिकल मेमोरी की जो 12 जीबी की
जो रैम है वह इसके दो जीबी से भी कम की
तरह परफॉर्म करता है यकीन मानिए तो इसलिए
यहां का दो जीबी भी जो है ना यहां का दो
जीबी व आपके फिजिकल के 12 16 जीबी से भी
कई ज्यादा गुना बेटर परफॉर्म करता
है ठीक
है
चलिए आज मैंने उम्मीद करी थी कि 100 प्लस
लोग लोग आएंगे कम से कम 200 प्लस बोला था
100 प्लस तो आ ही जाते बट आज काफी कम लोग
हैं बट कोई बात नहीं
चलेगा शायद बिजी होंगे यहां रिफ्रेश फिर
से कीजिए अभी भी इनिला इजिंग लिखा आ रहा
है अभी भी आपको कुछ नहीं करना है यू हैव
टू वेट फॉर इट टू पास द चेक आपको रिफ्रेश
कर करके आप देख सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं
अदर वाइज ये पास और वैसे भी आपको दिख
जाएगा सामने ठीक है ना तो फिलहाल मशीन तो
रन हो रही है बट यहां पे अभी इनिश इजिंग आ
रहा है तो आपको इंतजार करना पड़ेगा यह
मशीन को प्रोविजन करते हैं मशीन को आपको
अलॉट करते हैं क्लाउड में मशीन है आपको
पर्टिकुलर अलॉटमेंट किया जा रहा है बहुत
सारे यूजर्स है बहुत सारे लोग है क्लाउड
में सबको मशीन चाहिए सबको पर्टिकुलर
स्टोरेज चाहिए पर्टिकुलर प्रोसेसर चाहिए
उसी में से निकाल निकाल के सबको देना है
तो आपको भी निकाल के आपकी जो कन्फेशन उसके
अकॉर्डिंग दे रहे हैं उसमें थोड़ा इनको
टाइम लगता है प्रोविजन करने में तभी भी
इनिला हो रहा है एंड जैसे ही इनिला हो
जाएगा हमारा काम हो जाएगा
चलिए थोड़ा वेट
करते शांके मेरा भी सेटअप हो गया है सेम
आपके स्टेप तक पहुंच गया हूं बहुत बढ़िया
शांके वेरी गुड शांके आप अभी मेरे साथ चल
रहे हैं बहुत
बढ़िया और कौन-कौन है मेरे साथ शांके के
अलावा शांके इज गोइंग ग्रेट मतलब वो मेरे
तक अभी तक मेरे साथ साथ चल रहा है तो बहुत
अच्छी बात है शांके के अलावा कौन-कौन है
भाई साथ में मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार फिर से
रिफ्रेश मार देते हैं यस अब हो चुका है
यहां पे टू बाय टू चेक्स पास्ड जब ये हो
जाए यू आर गुड टू गो यू आर गुड टू लॉन्च
योर मशीन अब इस वाले इंस्टेंस आईडी पे
आपको क्लिक कर देना है एक बार सिंपल सा
जैसे ही आप क्लिक करेंगे इस मशीन की सारी
जो डिटेल्स हैं वो आपको यहां पे दिख
जाएंगी सारी डिटेल्स दिखेंगी ठीक है मैं
आपको दिखा रहा हूं ठीक है अभी फिलहाल के
लिए यहां पे आपको एक पब्लिक आईपी दिखेगी
और यहां पे एक प्राइवेट आईपी दिखेगी ये
प्राइवेट आईपी जब आप कनेक्ट कर लेंगे तो
आपकी आईपी एड्रेस होगी जो आपके अभी जैसे
मेरी आईपी एड्रेस क्या है आईपी कॉन्फ़िग
मेरे लोकल सिस्टम की आईपी देखोगे तो ये
आईपी एड्रेस है ना ये आईपी फर एड्रेस
प्राइवेट वाली उसी तरीके से ये प्राइवेट
आईपी है इंस्टेंट के साथ क्रिएट करोगे तो
उस मशीन की पर्टिकुलर जो मशीन आप चला रहे
होंगे ठीक है तो चलिए बहुत बढ़िया बात है
यार बहुत अच्छी बात है तो चलिए हो हो चुका
हमारा यहां पे अब अब आपको क्या करना है
गाइस अब आपको इस मशीन से कनेक्ट करना है
तो कनेक्ट वाले ऑप्शन पे क्लिक कीजिएगा ये
कनेक्ट ऑप्शन है ठीक है कनेक्ट ऑप्शन प
क्लिक कीजिएगा जैसे ही कनेक्ट प क्लिक
कीजिएगा आपको कनेक्ट करने के कुछ डिफरेंट
तरीके बताए जाएंगे ठीक है एक यहां पे आपको
टू इंस्टेंस कनेक्ट का बताया जाएगा जिससे
डायरेक्टली आप ट में ही कंसोल लच कर सकते
हैं सबसे एक बहुत अच्छी चीज है ये
देखिए एक बहुत अच्छी चीज है मैं कनेक्ट पर
क्लिक करूंगा ना यहां पे देखिए क्या
होगा एस्टेब्लिशिंग
कनेक्शन
अ एरर एस्टेब्लिशिंग एसस कनेक्शन टू योर
इंस्टेंस ठीक है एरर आ रही है अभी इसमें
यहां से बट ठीक है एक बार देख लेते हैं
कुछ प्रॉब्लम है
क्या यहां पे यूजर नेम भी है यूजर नेम आप
खुद का रख सकते हैं अगर कुछ चाहे तो रूट व
जो भी यूजर नेम आप डालना चाहे यू कैन पुट
यूजर नेम हियर फिलहाल यहां पे यूजर नेम जो
है वो रूट रखा हुआ है आप यूजर नेम जो चाहे
वो रख सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है तो
आपका यहां पे अ यहां पे आप सिंपल काली
मशीन रूट वगैरह जो भी यूजर नेम चाहे आप रख
सकते हैं उससे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं होगी ठीक
है फिलहाल के लिए मैं यहां पे फिर से एक
बार कनेक्ट करने की कोशिश करता हूं क्या
दिक्कत आ रही है इससे नहीं होगी शायद तो
देखते हैं ये एरर आ रही है कुछ कुछ
प्रॉब्लम आ रहा है चलो कोई बात नहीं हम अब
क्या करेंगे कनेक्ट पे क्लिक करेंगे और
हमें तो मशीन से वैसे से भी कनेक्ट करना
है ये मैं दिखा रहा था कि आप इस पे क्लिक
करेंगे तो इसके अंदर ही एक टर्मिनल ओपन हो
जाएगी एंड उसमें भी आप काम कर सकते हैं बट
हमें एसएसए से कनेक्ट करना है तो एसएसए
क्लाइंट पे आप आ जाइएगा सिंपल यहां पे आ
जाइएगा अब आपको अपने विंडोज मशीन पे आना
है किस पे आना है विंडोज पे या आप काली
में भी आ सकते हैं आप काली के टर्मिनल में
भी ये काम कर सकते हैं विज पे भी काम कर
सकते हैं सोचिए विज में ही सारा काम आप कर
रहे हैं विज का टर्मिनल ओपन कर लीजिएगा
मेरा टर्मिनल यहां पे ओपन हो चुका है विज
में एसएसए बाय डिफॉल्ट इंस्टॉल्ड आता है
शायद आप देख लीजिएगा यहां पे एसएसए लिख के
एंटर कीजिएगा कुछ इस तरीके की हेल्प फाइल
आ जाएगी एसएसए इंस्टॉल आता है या फिर ओपन
एसएसए क्लाइंट आप इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा
इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा आपका फिर आपका करेगा विज
में एसएसए बाय डिफॉल्ट आपका आ जाएगा यहां
पे एसएसए क्लिक के एंटर मारिए दिस विल बी
डन ठीक है सबका एसएसए विंडोज का टर्मिनल
ओपन कीजिए जो आपका टर्मिनल है ये वाला
विंडोज टर्मिनल एसएसए लिख के एंटर कीजिए
आपका एसएसए आ जाएगा इस तरीके से ठीक है
मैं यहां पे क्लियर कर देता हूं अब आपको
इस मशीन से कनेक्ट करना है कैसे कनेक्ट
करेंगे भाई देखिए लोकेट योर प्राइवेट की
फाइल ठीक है प्राइवेट की फाइल कौन सी थी
भैया यह वाली k linux.com इसको लोकेट करना
है यानी यह जिस लोकेशन पे है उस लोकेशन पे
हमें जाना पड़ेगा डाउनलोड्स में है तो मैं
सीडी डाउनलोड्स पे चलता हूं एंटर करता हूं
यहां एलएस करूंगा तो नहीं आएगा क्योंकि यह
कमांड काम नहीं करेगी डीडीआईआर कमांड
चलाते हैं डीआई आर पे आप जब कमांड चलाएंगे
तो आपको यहां पे कहीं ना
कहीं दिख जाएगी काली
linux.com ये फाइल यहां पे प्रेजेंट है
यानी हम सेम डायरेक्टरी में आ चुके हैं अब
जब सेम डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
का उस पर्टिकुलर फाइल का तो आप इसकी
परमिशन को थोड़ा रिड्यूस कर सकते हैं 400
पे लाके रिड्यूस कर सकते हैं बट हमें अभी
फिलहाल उसकी री नीड नहीं है तो आप उसके
साथ भी जा सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
कनेक्ट टू योर इंस्टेंस यूजिंग इट्स
पब्लिक डीएनएस आप पब्लिक डीएनएस का यूज कर
सकते हैं यहां पे जो पब्लिक डीएनएस यहां
पे मेंशन है आपका ये जो पर्टिकुलर आपका है
या तो आप आईपी एड्रेस के साथ कनेक्ट कर
सकते हैं कैसे करेंगे मैं आपको अब दिखाता
हूं आपका यूजर नेम रूट है याद रखिएगा तो
अब आपको कमांड लाना है
एसएसए हान आई उस फाइल के लिए काली वाली तो
काली
एंड यहां पर माय काली वाली इंस्टेंसस प
यहां पर हमें आईपी एड्रेस पब्लिक आईपी
एड्रेस यहां पर दिख रही है पब्लिक आईपी
एड्रेस इसको कॉपी कर लीजिएगा बस हो गया
पब्लिक आईपी एड्रेस को कॉपी किया यहां पे
एंड यहां पे आपको वो वाली आईपी एड्रेस
पेस्ट कर देनी है
दैट्ची स्टार्ट हो जानी चाहिए लेट्स ट्राई
एंड होप फॉर द बेस्ट यस कर देंगे यहां पे
आर यू शर वांट टू कनेक्ट यस और एंटर
करेंगे एंड एंड एंड
एंड यहां पे आप देखो य क्या आ रहा है यहां
पर आ रहा है प्लीज लॉग इन एस द यूजर काली
रदर देन द यूजर रूट अब ये बोल रहा है कि
आप काली यूजर की तरह यूज आप लॉग इन कीजिए
आप रूट यूजर में लॉगिन मत कीजिए इनका कहने
का मतलब यह है क्योंकि यह सिक्योरिटी परपस
से सही नहीं है हालांकि रूट यूजर हमारा
बना हुआ था बट स्टिल ये बोल रहे काली यूजर
से लॉग इन की चलिए ये जैसे बोलते हैं वैसे
करते हैं अब यहां रूट के जगह प काली लिख
दूंगा मैं काली काली
यूजर क्योंकि काली काली यूजर ऑटोमेटिक बाय
डिफॉल्ट बनती है हमारी तो काली यूजर में
किया एंटर किया एंड जैसे ही हमने एंटर
किया गाइस वी आर लॉग इन एंड आपके पास नाउ
वी यू हैव अ काली टर्मिनल हियर यू कैन सी
मैं यहां पे क्लियर कमांड चलाऊंगा लिनिक्स
के कमांड चलेंगे एंड अगर आप इसको देखेंगे
तो वी हैव द काली लेट्स सी कैट टीसी ओ
रिलीज एंड कांग्रेचुलेशन यू सक्सेसफुली
लॉन्च काली
रोलिंग क्या बात है अगर अब यहां से आपको
क्या करना है आप सबको भी पता है बट मैं
अभी और भी बहुत सारी चीजें बताऊंगा आप
देखते जाइए कितनी इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें होने
वाली है ठीक है अब ये
देखिए गट इट समझ में आ गया
चलिए कौन प्रमोशन कर रहा है
भाई
यह देख लिया काली आ गई अब एक बार सभी लोग
को कांग्रेचुलेशन सब कांग्रेचुलेशन बोलो
भाई एक दूसरे को काली हमारा लॉन्च हो चुका
है क्लाउड में एंड हमारे पास यह काली 20
23.4 है बहुत अच्छी बात है अब यहां पे गाइ
मैं इसको क्लियर कर देता हूं यहां पे यू
नेम
हाइन यू नेम हाइन ए आर्किटेक्चर यह देख
रहे होंगे काली लिनिक्स कर्नल वर्जन सब
कुछ मतलब काली हमारा बिल्कुल चलने लगा है
एकदम बिल्कुल परफेक्टली काम कर रहा है अब
यहां पे पीडब्ल्यूडी देंगे तो यहां पे होम
स्ल होम स्ल काली यह
आपका जीय आई भी डाल सकते हो भाई जीय आई भी
डाल सकते हो टेंशन मत लो वो भी मैं बता
दूंगा टेंशन मत लो ठीक है जीय आई भी डाल
सकते हो बट आपको जीआई की जरूरत नहीं है
भाई क्लाउड में मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं
क्लाउड में जब आप काली यूज करो बग हंटिंग
के लिए डोंट एवर यूज जीआई सबसे बेकार चीज
है जीआई को कभी यूज मत करो जीआई करोगे
आपकी एफिशिएंसी आपकी स्पीड कम हो जाएगी
ग्राफिक्स में बहुत ज्यादा यूटिलाइजेशन
होता है आपके डाटा का आपके पैकेट्स का
वहां बहुत ज्यादा जाएगा आपका एक्सपीरियंस
खराब हो जाएगा यूज द सीएआई सीएआई से जितनी
प्यार जितनी आपकी इन लगाव हो जाएगी उतना
आपको मजा आने लगेगा तो हम यहां पे आ चुके
हैं याद रखिएगा कैट
ईटीसी पास
डब्ल्यूडीवी है यानी कि आप रूट यूजर से भी
आ सकते हैं बट मैं आपको रिकमेंड करूंगा
डोंट फॉर द रूट यूजर ऑलवेज यूज द कमांड
सुडो व्हेन एवर रिक्वायर्ड जब भी
रिक्वायर्ड होगी सुडो कमांड का यूज कीजिए
एंड मस्त रहिए ठीक है चलिए अब सबसे पहला
कमांड सुडो एप्ट
अपडेट एप्ट अपडेट कमांड चलाना है लो भाई
हो गई अपडेट एप्ट अपडेट कमांड चलाया एंड
यहां पे आपकी कमांड मतलब यहां पे जो भी
चीजें अपडेट होनी थी ये अपडेट आपकी हो गई
इसके बाद एप्ट अपडेट के बाद आपको चला देना
है एप्ट अपग्रेड जिससे जो भी पैकेजेस
अपग्रेड होने हैं वो अपग्रेड हो जाएंगे
चलिए वो भी कर देते हैं पप
अपग्रेड एंड यहां पे सुडो नहीं लगाया तो
परमिशन डिनाइड का आ रहा है सुडो लगाना है
आपको सुडो एप्ट अपग्रेड एंड इट विल
अपग्रेड व्हाट एवर द ये देखिए ये देखिए
ओहो क्या बात है खत्म गेटिंग गेटिंग सारी
हो गई भाई यहां पे प्रोग्रेस चालू हो गया
जैसे ही अपग्रेड हो जाएगी आपके सामने सारी
अपग्रेडेड पैकेजेस आ जाएंगे तो आपका ऐप
अपग्रेड चल जाएगा अब यहां पे हम हंटिंग
अपना स्टार्ट करेंगे बहुत सारी चीजें करने
वाले हैं पहले तो आपको मैं दिखाऊंगा कैसे
क्या स्पीड डिफरेंस आएगा आपका जो आप लोकल
मशीन पर करते हैं या आप वीपीएस में क्लाउड
में कर रहे हैं आप सेम टर्मिनल काली का
यूज कर सकते हैं आपके काली l वर्चुअल मशीन
के अंदर में भी वर्चुअल मशीन में भी काली
का टर्मिनल ओपन करके एसएसए कमांड डाल के
आप इस मशीन से कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं विंडोज
में भी कर सकते हैं आपकी मर्जी है व ठीक
है बहुत बढ़िया शांके आपका भी हो
गया बहुत बढ़िया चलिए बढ़िया है आपका भी
जिनका जिनका हो गया अच्छी बात
है इट्स डी फिर से लेट हो ग लेट क्यों हो
जाते हो यार लेट मत हुआ करो भैया दोस्तों
को भी शेयर करो वीडियो को लेट मत हुआ
करो नहीं ऐसा कुछ नहीं है क्लाउड पे मशीन
है ना यार मशीन है क्लाउड पे अपडेटेड होगा
ऑलरेडी इसकी ऐसा कोई ऐसा कुछ नहीं है कि
वो ऑलरेडी अपडेटेड है क्योंकि वो क्लाउड
पे है ऐसा कुछ नहीं होता है ठीक है आपको
अपडेट करना पड़ेगा पैकेजेस को राइट यहां
पे यूज करंट वर्जन एंटर मार दीजिए का जो
लोकल है अभी करेंटली ट्स
इट ओके ट्स इट नहीं इतना टाइम अभी नहीं
लेंगे फुल अपग्रेड में अभी फुल अपग्रेड आप
लोग कर लीजिएगा करना होगा तो बट फिलहाल के
लिए जरूरत नहीं है फिलहाल अपग्रेड एप्ट
अपडेट अपग्रेड बस बात
खत्म चलिए तो हमारा यहां पर काम हो चुका
क्लियर कर देता हूं मैं अब यहां पर सबसे
पहले सबसे पहले क्या करना है मान लो
हमें व्हाट वी हैव टू डू सब डोमेन फाइंड
करनी है क्या सब फाइंडर चाहिए सब फाइंडर
इंस्टॉल करना है तो चलिए सब फाइंडर
इंस्टॉल कर लेते हैं सुडो एप इंस्टॉल सब
फाइंडर एंड
दैट्ची जिएगा सब फाइंडर आपका स्टार्ट हो
जाएगा इस तरीके से ये देखिए स्टार्ट हो
गया इसकी लोकेशन देख लेते हैं ए ए हान a
तो यहां पे आपको डॉट कॉन्फेक्त
हैं यहां पे अभी स फाइंडर की कोई डिटेल्स
नहीं आ रही है क्योंकि अभी तक हमने टूल को
रन नहीं किया है ट्स वई कोई अभी डिटेल
यहां पे नहीं आ रही है तो सब फाइंडर को एक
बार रन कर लेंगे और कोई बात नहीं है सब
फाइंडर नडी एंड यहां पे एक चला देते हैं
कोई सा भी एक डोमेन पे मान
लो
tesla.svs 666 सब डोमन सेकंड में आ गए
आपके य दिख रहा है ना आप लोगों को दो
सेकंड 825 मिली सेकंड में 666 सबने फाइंड
कर दि सिंपल यह दिख गया
सबको यह सबको दिखा भाई चलिए यह देख लेते
हैं अब इसकी फाइल क्रिएट हो गई एलस में सब
फाइंडर नाम की डायरेक्टरी आ गई सीडी सब
फाइंडर एलस करेंगे कॉन्ग डवाल फाइल अभी
जनरेट होके आई है की एक और फाइल जनरेट
होती है वो फाइल अभी जनरेट नहीं हुई है वो
भी फाइल जनरेट हो जाएगी जब आप कोई भी काम
ऐसा करेंगे कोई जब जब यह कमांड अब चलाएंगे
देखिए सब फाइंडर
tesla.svs जस्ट वेट एंड
वच देख रहे हो स्पीड देख रहे हो भाई
इसकी धमाकेदार
स्पीड अरे यह देखो 732 सब डोमेन इसने
फाइंड किए ऑल सोर्सेस पर किए ठीक है
732 यहां पे इसने फाइंड किए हैं सब डोमेंस
स्पीड देखो स्पी वाओ क्या बात है ये इतने
इसने फाइंड कर लिए
भाई अब यहां पे जब क्लियर करूंगा या एलस
करूंगा तो यहां पे अब प्रोवाइडर्स
config.yml फाइल आ गई वही वाली जिसके अंदर
आप एपीआई कीज
कंफिल में करते हो सिंपल एपीआई कीज कन्फर
कर लीजिएगा और भी बढ़िया हो जाएगा अब चलिए
अब एक काम करते हैं अब क्या काम करते हैं
जो हमारा काम बचा हुआ है वो काम करते हैं
अब यहां पे हमें एक कोई भी टारगेट लेना है
एंड उसके सब डोमस को फाइंड कर लेना है
पहले टारगेट कौन सा ले बताइए मुझे चैट में
आप लोग
5 सेकंड में 7531 सब डोमेन वही तो बात है
यही तो खूबी है भाई क्लाउड की यही तो खूबी
है लोकल मशीन पर करते रह जाएंगे कोई एक
टारगेट बताइए मुझे एंड वी विल यूज सब
फाइंडर हाइ फन डी टारगेट जो बताएंगे वो हम
टारगेट यहां पर लगाएंगे कोई भी एक टारगेट
चूज
करके चलिए लेट मी नो द टारगेट गाइस जल्दी
बताए टारगेट
को
अन
एल ब क्राउड से ले लो आप ही लोग बता दो
यार बकरो से तो ले लेंगे आप लोग बता
दो ओके काफी सारे टारगेट आ रहे
हैं
चलिए चलिए तो हम क्या करते हैं गाइस हम
टेस्ला को ही चूज कर लेते हैं टेस्ला ही
रखते हैं ठीक है टेस्ला ही रख लेते हैं
चलिए टेस्ला ही रख लेते हैं कोई बात नहीं
तो
tesla.svs
रूट में आ जाते हैं डायरेक्टली यहां पे
एलएस करेंगे यहां
पे ठीक है एलएस हान a यस वी आर इन द होम
डायरेक्टरी स् होम काली इसी में हम यहां
पे अब सब फाइंडर यूज कर लेते
हैं ओके चलिए
tesla.svs ला एंड लेट्स वेट फॉर द रिजल्ट
चलिए देखते
हैं गिविंग द
रिजल्ट्स क्या बोल रहे हो भाई
पलव बोल क्या रहे हो पहले यह तो
बताओ चलो वी गट
हियर
वी गॉट हियर गट हियर 732 सब डोमस मिले
हमें चलिए बढ़िया है एक फाइल जनरेट हो गई
होगी
tesla.svs बताइए क्या करना है इसके बाद
सबडस फाइंड कर लिया इसके बाद क्या करना
है जल्दी
बताओ लेट मी नो
गाइस ठीक है टेस्ला को फिक्स रखते हैं
फिलहाल के लिए चलिए बताइए
जल्दी शॉटिंग तो तब करेंगे मल्टीपल फाइल्स
होंगी ना मल्टीपल तो शॉटिंग करेंगे ना
इसमें तो एक ही जो निकले होंगे वही निकले
होंगे यार जी हां ए टीपी एक बिल्कुल सही
मोर सब डोमेंस आप फाइंड कर सकते हैं और भी
सब डोमेंस यू कैन फाइंड अगर आपको और भी सब
डोमेंस फाइंड करने हैं यू कैन फाइंड मोर
सब डोमेंस ठीक है एंड यहां पे हम शफल
डीएनएस का यूज कर सकते हैं याद रखिए गाइ
वी कैन यूज द शफल डीएनएस चलिए मैं आपको
बताया था ना शफल डीएनएस चलिए शफल डीएनएस
का एक बार देख लेते हैं
अ एटलिस्ट
शफल डीएनएस ये शायद यहां होगा नहीं
लिस्टिंग में ठीक है अब यहां पे देख लेते
हैं शफल डीएनएस चलिए अ यहां चलते हैं एंड
चलते हैं शफल डीएनएस
पे यहां पर आ जाते हैं एंड हाउ इट कैन बी
इंस्टॉल्ड पाइथन हमारे इंस्टॉल है
क्या पाइथन पाइथन देखते हैं पाइथन कौन सा
है पाइथन 3 इंस्टॉल नहीं है ठीक
है ओके एट
[संगीत]
इंस्टॉल
3 क्या रहा है अच्छा स्पेलिंग गलत लिख
दिया प
इंस्टॉल सुडो लगाना जरूर भूलना मत पाइथन 3
पाइथन 3 हमने इंस्टॉल कर दिया ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल है पाइथन 3 लिख के एंटर कीजिए जी
हा तो पाइथन 3 ऑलरेडी हमारा इंस्टॉल है
हमने पाइथन रखा हुआ है बढ़िया
है एवरीथिंग इ गुड नाउ लेट्स डू हम शफल
डीएनएस को इंस्टॉल करेंगे इसके लिए हमें
गो लैंग्वेज की जरूरत है गो हमें इंस्टॉल
करनी पड़ेगी तो सुडो एट इंस्टॉल गोलंग
गोलंग को इंस्टॉल किए बिना आप नहीं यूज कर
सकते हैं तो गोलंग को हम इंस्टॉल कर लेते
हैं पहले फर्स्ट वी विल इंस्टॉल गोलंग
चलिए इंस्टॉल होने देते हैं उसके बाद यहां
पे एक सिंपल सा कमांड होगा इसको इंस्टॉल
करने का लेट्स सी हाउ टू इंस्टॉल यह रहा
इंस्टॉलेशन गो का कॉपी कर लीजिए यहां पे
एंड
दैट्ची
बिल्कुल सब सब डोमेन भी आप आप फाइंड
कीजिएगा आपको उसमें टाइम थोड़ा लगेगा बट
सब सब डोमेन भी फाइंड कीजिए जितने सब
डोमेन फाइंड कर सकते हैं फाइंड कीजिए सफल
डीएनएस या इसके अलावा और भी बहुत सारे
टूल्स है सबसे ट्राई कीजिए सबसे जितने सब
डोमस फाइंड कर सकते हैं फाइंड कीजिए
शॉटिंग कीजिए उसके बाद यूनिक सब डोमस को
निकालिए एंड फिर एसटीडीपी एक वाला काम
कीजिए तो यह भी काम हमारा हो गया अब यहां
पे गो वाला हमने डाला और एंटर कर दिया
लेट्स सी
नाउ शुड इंस्टॉल शफल डीएनएस एंड कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं आनी चाहिए शायद अगर इसको
इंस्टॉल इसको यूज करने में देखते हैं
चलिए लेट्स सी
गाइस चलिए ऑलमोस्ट हो चुकी है यहां पे
इंस्टॉल हमारी शफल डीएनएस अब इसको रन करते
हैं रन करके देखते
हैं
इट्स इंस्टॉलिंग जस्ट वेट वेट एंड
वेट
ओके थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा बट हो जाएगा आपका
इंस्टॉल राइट शफल
डीएनएस शफल
नस
शफल डीएनएस को आप लोकल सिस्टम पर इंस्टॉल
कीजिएगा तो उसमें थोड़ा ज्यादा टाइम लग
जाएगा आपको बट ठीक है यहां पर हम ट्राई
करते हैं याद रखिएगा शफल डीएनएस को यूज
करने के लिए मास डीएनएस का इंस्टॉल होना
जरूरी है तो वो भी आपको इंस्टॉल करना पड़
जाएगा मास डीएनएस रिमेंबर दिस ठीक
है
सफल डीएनएस को ऐसे इंस्टॉल करने के बाद
यहां
[संगीत]
पे ओके हो गया सफल नेस इंस्टॉल हो गई चलिए
अब यहां पे मास डीएनएस को भी इंस्टॉल कर
लेते हैं सुडो ए इंस्टॉल मास डी डीस बिकॉज
इसके बिना शफल डीएनएस आपका काम नहीं करता
है इसी का एक फॉक है चलिए हो गया अब शफल
डीएनएस को स्टार्ट करके देखते हैं होप
फुली क्या हो रहा है
यह इट्स नॉट गेटिंग एलस करते हैं
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हो रहा ये क्यों नहीं हो
रहा सीडी गो एस करते यहां पे सीडी बिन
यहां पे सफल डीएनएस है क्या है तो सफल
डीएनएस ओके गो पाथ सेट नहीं है इसलिए सफल
डीएनएस जो है वो आपका काम नहीं कर रहा है
गो पाथ आपको सेट कर देना पड़ता है बिना गो
पाथ सेट किए आप सफल डीएनएस को यूज नहीं कर
सकते यहां पे आपका गो पाथ क्या है आप देख
लीजिए यहां पे गो पाथ जो है आपका यहां पे
पीडब्ल्यूडी ये आपका ये है गो बिन ये वाला
पाथ जो है ना आपका काली के अंदर ये आपका
गो पाथ है चलिए यहां पे क्या कर देते
हैं सेट गो पाथ काली एंड एक्सपोर्ट वाली
जो कमांड
वो लगा देते हैं यहां पर एंड यहां पर यहां
पर फटाफट आ जाओ फटाफट आ जाओ फटाफट आ जाओ
फटाफट आ जाओ फटाफट आ जाओ चलिए यहां पर
यहां पर हम क्या कर देते हैं फटाफट
निकालते हैं
एंड दिस वन
स्पोर्ट गो अरे भाई आजा भाई क्या कर रहा
है
[संगीत]
गोरू लेट्स गो टू
इंस्टॉल
यह वाला ठीक
[संगीत]
है यहां पर यह कर
दिया बेसिकली पाथ आपको यहां पे मेंशन करना
पड़ेगा दूसरा ऑप्शन आपके पास नहीं है मैं
यहां पे पाथ मेंशन कर देता हूं गो का अ
सिंपल यहां
पे एक सिंगल कमांड मुझे यहां पे चाहिए
सिंगल कमांड वाली मिल नहीं रही है सिंगल
कमांड लेट्स फाइंड द सिंगल कमांड क्यों
मल्टीपल मुझे नहीं लगाने है यहां पे सिंगल
एक गो का पाथ लगा देते हैं ठीक है जस्ट
वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट कहां गया कहां गया
यस ये रहा ये रहा ये रहा ये
रहा अ चलिए तो यहां पे मैं गो पाथ सेट कर
देता हूं यहां पे
[संगीत]
एक यहां पे एक गो पाथ सेट कर देते हैं
एक्सपोर्ट गो पाथ यह वाला काम आपको कर
देना है ठीक है होम स्ल गो यह वाला पाथ है
बेसिकली जो आपको सेट कर देना है होम स्ल
गो पे एंड नेक्स्ट इज नेक्स्ट इज यहां
पे अब इसको कैसे सेट करना है मैं आपको यह
भी बता देता हूं ठीक है सिंपल पहले तो यह
वाला एंड फिर आपको ये वाला ये दोनों चीजें
ये दोनों चीजें मैंने यहां पे कॉपी कर ली
मान लो यहां पे मैं यहां पे कॉपी कर लेता
हूं क्योंकि हमारा पाथ जो है वो बेसिकली
अ स्लैश मतलब होम डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
z एसए आरसी यहां पे आप कोई भी लोकेशन जो
है वो सेट कर सकते हैं पाथ सेट कर सकते
हैं एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल सेट कर सकते हैं
जैसे आप
[संगीत]
linux.com गाइज हमें पाथ सेट करना है सबसे
नीचे चले जाएंगे ठीक है जैसे यहां पे बहुत
सारे पाथ ऑलरेडी आपको सेट मिलेंगे बट यहां
पे हम पहले पाथ सेट करेंगे यहां पे नीचे आ
जाएंगे सबसे नीचे आ जाएंगे गो टू द डाउन
डाउन डाउन एंड लास्ट में चले जाएंगे ठीक
है यहां लास्ट में आ गए अब यहां पे हमने
वो जो कॉपी किया था यहां पे हम पेस्ट कर
देते हैं ये पाथ अब यहां पे क्या इसका
मतलब क्या है कि गो पाथ को आप सेट कर
दीजिए होम
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री कर दिया एंड
दैट्ची आपको करना होता है ये कर दिया हमने
यहां पे
दैट्ची ठीक है एंटर कर दीजिएगा हो गया
उसके बाद आपको करना है सोर्स ताकि अपडेट
कर दीजिए आप ये काम करना है आपको सोर्स
करेंगे तो आपका जो भी आपने चेंजेज किए हैं
इस पर्टिकुलर जेडएस एचआरसी फाइल में वो
अपडेट हो जाएगी एंटर करेंगे अपडेट हो गई
दैट्ची से स्टार्ट करेंगे तो सफल डीएनएस
यहां से एज कमांड लच होगा क्योंकि आपने
उसका पाथ सेट कर दिया है ये एक बहुत ही
अच्छी खूबी है आपकी जेएसए आर सी फाइल की
या प्रोफाइल फाइल की जहां आप जाके एक
पर्टिकुलर किसी भी अ लोकेशन को सेट कर
सकते हैं जैसे क्या होता है ना अगर आपको
जब आपने अगर ये सेट नहीं किया जाता ना
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल अगर आपको शफल डीएनएस
स्टार्ट करना होता अगर आपको एग्जीक्यूट
कराना होता तो कैसे करते पहले आप गो के
पाथ पे जाते कहां पे
जाते सीडी कहां पे है गो का पाथ एलएस
साइफन ए दे दीजिए यह देखिए गो यहां पे है
यह गो तो सीडी गो करते हैं यहां पे
आप उसके बाद एलएस करते सीडी बिन करते आप
और एलएस करोगे यहां शफल डीएनएस अब यहां से
आके आपको एग्जीक्यूट कर करना पड़ता डॉट
स्ल शफल डीएनएस ऐसे करके या डायरेक्टली आप
शफल डीएनएस यहां से भी आप यहां से करते
शफल डीएनएस इस तरीके से आपको शफल डीएन
आपको एग्जीक्यूट करना पड़ता गो के पाथ प
जाके बट अगर आपने गो पाथ सेट कर दिया है
तो आप किसी भी लोकेशन पे रहे किसी भी
प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
जैसे ही आपने हान एस दिया इसकी हेल्प फाइल
आ गई एंड एवरीथिंग इज वर्किंग परफेक्टली
अब सफल डीएन से कैसे करना है भैया हान डी
लगा देना है अपने को चलिए हान डी लगा देते
हैं सफल
डीएनएस याद रखिएगा सफल डीएनएस के लिए हमें
एक वड लिस्ट भी चाहिए वड लिस्ट हान डब्
देके देखो यहां पे कहां गया वड
लिस्ट न डब् भाई वाफ हान डब कहां गया यह
रहा हाफ वर्डलिस्ट चाहिए वर्डलिस्ट जिसमें
ब्रूट फोर्स करना है डोमेन को वो वाली
वर्ड लिस्ट चाहिए अब वो वर्ड लिस्ट कहां
मिलेगी मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ था कि
हम एसेट
नोट एसेट नोट वर्डलिस्ट से भी ले सकते हैं
वर्डलिस्ट यह वाली यहां पे आप आएंगे तो
यहां पे आपको दिख जाएगा दिस वन 2 मिलियन
सब डोमन t एकटी ये भी आपको मिल जाएगी 28
एब की बेस्ट डीएनएस वर्ड लिस्ट ये भी आपको
मिल जाएगी बहुत सारे वर्ड लिस्ट यहां पे
मिल जाएंगे चलिए ये हम थोड़ा ज्यादा ले
लेते हैं बेस्ट डीएनएस वर्डलिस्ट जो है ना
यही वाली फाइल हम ले सकते हैं यह वाली
फाइल हम चला सकते सकते हैं ठीक है बट वही
है कि इसको अब चलाना है तो कैसे चलाना है
भैया यह भी आपको देखना पड़ेगा थोड़ा सा ये
भी आपको समझना पड़ेगा ठीक है तो अब हम इस
बेस्ट डीएनएस वर्ड लिस्ट को हम यहां पे
लेकर आ सकते हैं वी कैन ब्रिंग इट हियर
चलिए या तो कोई सा भी आप वर्ड लिस्ट ले
लीजिए या तो इसके अंदर ही कोई वर्ड लिस्ट
हो तो उसको भी ले लीजिए जैसे मैं यहां पे
चलता हूं क्लियर करता हूं एंड यहां देखते
हैं सीडी स् यूएसआर शेयर वर्डलिस्ट
ओके व लिस्ट नहीं है य पर
ना ओके देर इ नो लिस्ट लेट्स
फाइंड
या लिस्ट नहीं है बिकॉज टूल ही नहीं है
यहां पर वो वाले टूल्स नहीं है वो वाले
टूल्स अगर आप इंस्टॉल करेंगे तो वो टूल जो
है वो वड लिस्ट आ जाएंगी सोय काम करते हैं
प इंस्टॉल एंड देन वी आर ट्राइट डब्लू
फज
या सूडो लेट्स ट्राई टू इंस्टॉल इट व आर
इंस्टॉलिंग इट लेट्स इंस्टॉल डबल फज हो
गया अब कर लेते हैं प
इंस्टॉल सो ए इंस्टॉल डीआई आर
सर्च क्योंकि इसकी रिक्वायरमेंट तो हमें
पढ़ने ही वाली है इन सबकी तो डीआर सर्च भी
हमने इंस्टॉल कर
लिया बढ़िया प इंस्टॉल डीआई
आर डीआई आर बी डीडीआईआर बस्टर डीआई आर बी
भी इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं एंड र बस्टर भी
इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हैं ठीक है तो डीआर बी और डीआर बस्टर
दोनों इंस्टॉल कर लेते हैं ट्स ग्रेट एंड
इट्स डन
[संगीत]
नाउ
चलो बढ़िया है शांके अच्छी बात
है कोई बात नहीं जो लेट से
आए चलिए यहां पर मैं तब तक यह हो रहा है
इंस्टॉल तब तक मैं एक सेशन जो है वो
स्टार्ट कर देता
हूं जस्ट वेट
गाइस
यस
लेट मी स्टार्ट सेशन चलिए यह काम हो गया
एंड होप फुली अब हमारे पास आ गई
होगी जस्ट वेट गाइस जस्ट जस्ट अ
सेकंड
ओके
लेट मी सी यर एंड यहां पर मैं चलो हो गया
इधर का काम हो गया चलिए बढ़िया ओके तो डन
यहां पर इंस्टॉल हो चुका है अब हम देखते
हैं सीडी स्ल यूएसआर शेयर एंड वड लिस्ट
बना कि नहीं अभी
करेंटली नो नो नो नो एक काम करते हैं
ना शयर य शेयर डीर सर्च डीर बी में चलते
हैं डीर बी में चलते हैं एलस करते हैं
यहां पर वर्ड लिस्ट आ गई यहां पर वड
लिस्ट सीडी वर्ड लिस्ट वड लिस्ट आ चुकी है
हमारी एलस करते हैं कौन सी वर्ड लिस्ट आई
है
भैया ओके तो बहुत सारी बिग ड एक्सटी आ गई
यहां पर यह वाली सारी आ गई चलो बहुत सारी
आ गई बढ़िया है ना
यार ओके बढ़िया अब हम क्या करते हैं अब
हम लेट्स
वैसे तो हम यहां से वर्डलिस्ट एक बार
ट्राई करते हैं डाउनलोड कर लेने का एक बार
वी विल ट्राई टू डाउनलोड इट राइट
तो सो लेट्स गो टू दिस वर्डलिस्ट
लोकेशन डाउनलोड लोकेशन हेयर इट इज एंड वटी
यहां से मैं कॉपी कर लेता हूं इस पाथ को
बेस्ट डीएनएस वाली एंड यहां से एक बार
ट्राई कर लेते हैं डाउनलोड करने की ठीक है
सो इफ वी कैन गेट टू डाउनलोड इट तो डब्लू
गेट कर लेते हैं एंड यहां पे हमने ये वाली
लोकेशन दे दी एंड इंस्टॉल एंटर कर देते
हैं नाउ वी आर वेटिंग फॉर डाउनलोड टू
कंप्लीट यह देखिए स्पीड देखिए भाई क्या
स्पीड है ओ माय गॉड स्पीड देख रहे हो भाई
क्या स्पीड आ रही थी
खतरनाक डाउनलोड स्पीड है यार डाउनलोड
स्पीड 22 एमबी पर सेकंड की आ रही है इतनी
खतरनाक स्पीड है
चलिए ठीक है डन यह वाली वर्डलिस्ट हमारे
पास आ चुकी है बेस्ट डीएन व स हम
इंडिविजुअल वर्डलिस्ट भी डाल चुके हैं बट
ठीक है बेस्ट डीएनएस वाली हम यूज कर सकते
हैं इसके लिए कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है अब
यहां पे काम हो चुका अब सफल डीएनएस वाली
हम कमांड यूज
करेंगे क्लियर शफल डीएनएस हान h
[संगीत]
दैट्ची है हमारा जो हमारा जो टारगेट है वो
कर हाइन डब् एंड हमने कर दिया बेस्ट
डीएनएस वाली वड लिस्ट को यूज एंड हाइन आर
रिजॉल्वर हां जी रिजॉल्वर भी यूज करना है
हमें तो हमें यहां पर रिजॉल्वर भी डालना
पड़ेगा यार रिजॉल्वर्स भी चाहिए हमें सो
लेट्स फाइंड सम रिजॉल्वर्स
लेट्स गेट सम रिजॉल्वर्स रिजॉल्वर्स डटी
एक्सटी सॉरी तो यह रही मास डीएनएस वाली
रिजॉल्वर यही यही वाली मास डीएनएस वाली है
इसको हमने क्या
किया वट व आर गोइंग टू
ू गोइंग टू गेट दिस रिजॉल्वर रिजॉल्वर टू
सो डब् गेट एंड यह रिजॉल्वर भी हम डाउनलोड
कर लेते हैं सो हो चुका हमारा रिजॉल्वर भी
आ चुका है बढ़िया अब वी आर गुड टू गो शफल
डीएनएस हाफ
डी हान से इसकी हेल्प फाइल देख लेते हैं
एक बार चलिए अब यहां पर हान डी देते हैं
t.com उसके बाद क्या करना है
गाइस
tesla.svs
डाल दिया हमने एंड
दैट्ची h w में तो h o डाल दिया एंड यहां
पे
ला ला
शफल
txt.gz तो यहां पे अब यह काम करना स्टार्ट
हो रहा है एंड होप फुली ये रन हो जाएगा
चलिए एग्जीक्यूटिंग मास डीएनएस ऑन
tesla's आउटपुट के लिए ठीक है बट वेट करते
हैं चलिए
जस्ट वेडिंग वेडिंग एंड वेडिंग जस्ट
वेटिंग
राइट ओके लेट्स क्लोज इट एंड लेट्स सी इफ
एनीथिंग इ जनरे और नॉट कुछ हुआ है कि नहीं
टेस्ला शफल t एकटी जनरेट हुई है कि नहीं
हुई है भी कुछ ऐसे जनरेशन नहीं हुई है तो
एक काम करते हैं लेट्स डू वन थिंग काफी
बड़ी फाइल है यह बट ठीक है बट ठीक है देर
सम देर मस्ट बी समथिंग सम इश्यूज
आल्सो यहां पे काम करते हैं सेम सेम कमांड
में ला शफल ही रहने देते हैं रिजॉल्वर ठीक
है रहने देते हैं यहां पे एंड व यूजिंग
नवी एंड लेट्स ट्राई टू
सी ओके जस्ट वेट
नाउ एंड अगर यह फिर भी काम नहीं करेगा तो
देर सम देयर माइट बी सम इश्यूज विद द शफल
डीएनएस राइट नाउ एंड वी कैन ट्राई वंस
अगेन फॉर अगेन सम अदर रिजॉल्वर्स आल्सो सो
डीएनएस रिजॉल्वर्स टी एक्सटी लेट्स फाइंड
सम अदर सेक लिस्ट का एक रिजॉल्व
नस रिजॉल्वर इसको भी हम इसको भी डाउनलोड
कर लेते हैं ओके ल डाउनलोड दिस टू एंड देन
ल
सी ठीक है सो लेट्स क्लोज इट एंड लेट्स एक
काम करते हैं इसको रिजॉल्वर को भी डाउनलोड
कर लेते
हैं व्ट आई एम डूइंग डबल गेट एंड देन य
रिजॉल्वर रिजॉल्वर इसको भी डाउनलोड कर
लिया इसके बाद हम ये वाली छोटी वाली फाइल
भी डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं ये जो छोटी फाइल
है ना हमरी क्या किस चीज
की एसेट नोट वाली जो छोटी वाली हमारी सब
डोमेन वाली है 28
अ 28 एबी
की इस पर चलते हैं लेट्स कॉपी इट लोकेशन
एंड लेट्स डाउनलोड
इट 2 मिलियन सब डोमेन हम इसको भी डाउनलोड
कर लेते हैं छोटी वाली फाइल जो है इसको भी
कर लेते हैं एक बार जस्ट वेट एंड डन नाउ
इन द सेम कमांड वी आर रिप्लेसिंग समथिंग
हम यहां
पे टेस्ला शफ डटी एकटी कर देते हैं यहां
पर हम रिजॉल्वर टीटी के जगह पे डीएनएस
वाला यूज कर लेते
हैं डीएनए रिजॉल्व एक्टी एंड यहां पे
बेस्ट डीएनएस के जगह प हम 2 मिलियन वाली
वडली जो है वो यूज कर लेते हैं एंड देन
प्रेस एंटर एंड देन लेट्स वेट हमारा यह
काम करता है कि नहीं करता है ठीक है कोई
बात नहीं अगर कोई टूल एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हो
पा रही है किसी भी वजह से किसी भी
प्रॉब्लम से देन डोंट वरी अबाउट दैट राइट
उसके लिए आपको टेंशन नहीं लेनी है वेट
करना है आपको कभी-कभी टूल्स में
प्रॉब्लम्स आती है तो यू कैन ट्राई सम अदर
टूल्स ल्स
राइट साउंड प्रॉब्लम साउंड इशू आ रहे हैं
क्या आप लोगों को मुझे तो सही लग रहा है
साउंड
यार साउंड तो सही लग रही है मुझे तो
ओके आप सफल डीएनएस यूज करिएगा बाकी और भी
बहुत सारे ल डीएनएस है आप उसका यूज कर
सकते हैं दे मल्टीपल सब डोमेन फाइंडर
टूल्स मल्टीपल सब डोम फाइंड करना है कहने
का मतलब बस यह है ठीक है
ओके कोई भी टूल जो काम कर रहा है आप उसको
यूज कीजिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है य फिलहाल के
लिए सफल डीन इ नॉट गिविंग एनी रिजल्ट राइट
एक काम करते हैं लेट्स
गो टू सफल डोस गिट पेज एंड लेट्स सी इफ
देर इ सम
इश्यूज रिजॉल्वर एक्सलेंट यहां पर यूज
किया इन्होंने
ठीक
है नथिंग नथिंग नो इश्यूज यर सफल के साथ
कोई दिक्कत तो ऐसे है
नहीं
यहां पर हमने सीधा-सीधा डलिस यूज किया
रिजॉल्वर यूज किया और कुछ यूज किया नहीं
है सो एवरीथिंग इ
परफेक्ट राइट एंड इशू हम चेक कर सकते हैं
लेट्स गो टू द इशू सेक्शन लेटस चेक इ देर
इन इशू कोई प्रॉब्लम है क्या य
पे क्लोज इशू में चलते हैं कोई रिजल्ट तो
हमें नहीं मिल रहा यहां पर अप स्ट्रीम
राउटर क्रशिंग ठीक है कुड नॉट क्रिएट रनर
कुड नॉट क्रिएट मास बाइनरी ठीक
है हाउ टू इंटीग्रेट ठीक है और यूल्स कोई
और ऐफ डज नॉट डू एनीथिंग हा ये देख लेते
हैं यह बग टाइप है लग रहा है
शायद ओके दिस इज काइंड ऑफ बग आई थिंक सेम
प्रॉब्लम लेटेस्ट है ये आई हैव आल्सो सेम
प्रॉब्लम ऑन गो वर्जन इतना ठीक
है
मज मज थैंक्स फॉर रिपोर्टिंग दिस इज नाउ
फिक्स इन द लेटेस्ट रिलीज ओके लेटेस्ट
रिलीज में इन्होंने फिक्स कर दिया है ऐसा
बोल रहे हैं ये लेटेस्ट रिलीज मुझे ऐसा
लगता नहीं है क्योंकि शफल डीएनएस को हमने
अपडेट कर दिया होगा शायद लेटेस्ट वर्जन ही
है शफल डीएनएस का सो देर इज नो एनी अपडेट
देर इज नो एनी अपग्रेड राइट कोई बात नहीं
चलिए लेटेस्ट रिजॉल्वर्स आप यूज करके
ट्राई कर सकते हैं बट आई डोंट थिंक सो दैट
वुड बी वर्किंग क्योंकि मुझे ऐसा कुछ लग
नहीं रहा
देख लेते हैं एक्स टेस्टेड टेस्टेड
रिजॉल्व टी एक्सटी इसको भी देख लेते हैं
ट्र रिवर प कोई और रिजॉल्वर यूज कर लेते
हैं सो दिस इज रिजॉल्वर ट्रस्टेड
रिजॉल्वर्स ट्रस्टेड वाली जो है इसको भी
हम ट्राई कर लेते हैं चलो कोई भी हम
छोड़ेंगे नहीं ज्यादा नहीं है कमी ही है
बट वी विल ट्राई ऑन इट राइट इसको हटा देते
हैं पहले तो हम इसको डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं
सो वी गट द ट्रस्टेड रिजॉल्वर्स आल्सो वे
इट इ रिजॉल्वर्स ट्रस्टेड राइट सेम कमांड
व विल बी रिप्लेसिंग द रिजॉल्वर
फाइल एंड वल
बी रिप्लेसिंग रिजॉल्वर्स टेस्टेड ड
एक्सटी एंड अगेन वल ट्राई दिस ला क लेट्स
ओके लेट्स ट्राई टू चेंज द टारगेट एक बार
एक बार टारगेट चेंज कर लेते हैं टारगेट को
हम रख लेते हैं
फ नहीं नहीं ऐसे
facebook's का ही रख लेता हूं
lenskart.com इसको ही रख लेते हैं एंड
लेट्स
ट्राई इससे कुछ फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा बट स्टिल
वी विल सी व्हाट इज़
हैपनिंग नो सो इट्स इशू ऑफ़ सफल डीएनएस आई
थिंक इस टूल की प्रॉब्लम होगी कुछ अभी
करेंटली उसको देखना पड़ेगा आपको इश्यूज
में जाके देखिएगा मैं भी देखूंगा क्या
इश्यूज आ रहे हैं अगर इस टूल के अंदर कुछ
भी इश्यूज हैं आई विल बी लेटिंग यू नो
सबको मैं बताऊंगा ग्रुप में चैनल जो है
हमारा ठीक है तो क्योंकि यहां पर कोई भी
ऐसा इशू आ नहीं रहा है कुछ ऐसा दिख नहीं
रहा है जो इशू करेंटली अभी हो जो नॉट वर्क
यह वाली चीज आई
है और तो कुछ यहां पर दिख नहीं रहा
है नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग
नथिंग ओके देर नथिंग दे नो इशू हियर
कोई ऐसा कुछ इशू यहां पर कुछ है नहीं यहां
पे मेंशन भी नहीं है यहां पर कुछ वर्क भी
नहीं कर रहा है सो लेट्स स्किप इट इसको
छोड़ देते हैं हमारे पास ऑलरेडी एक हमारे
पास सब डोमेन की लिस्ट है हम आगे इस पर
प्रोसेस करते हैं लिस्ट क्या है
टेस्ला सॉरी लाटी एकटी हमारे पास फाइल कौन
सी है भैया टेस्ला एक्टी कितने हमारे सब
डोमेन है लाड सफन ए सॉरी हान एल वी हैव
732 सब डोमस अब 732 सब डोमस जो हमारे पास
हैं इस पे हमें चलाना है
http1 क्या चलाना है भैया लाइव
http.get एंड देन इसको एक फाइल में डाल
देना है टेस्ला लाइव डटी एक्सटी ठीक है
लाला में आ जाएगा यह एंड हमारे पास जो बचे
सब डोमस होंगे उन पर फदर प्रोसेसिंग भी
करेंगे सफल डीस किसी का काम कर रहा है बता
दीजिएगा
मुझे यस इ द टूल प्रॉब्लम इ इन टूल राइट
टूल में प्रॉब्लम
है
या चलिए हो गया यस यू कैन यूज प्योर
डीएनएस सही है यहां पर हमारा फाइल बन के आ
चुका होगा दैट इज लाला एक्टी देख लेते हैं
टेस्ला लाइव लाला एकटी में कितने सब डोमस
इसने हमें फाइंड करके दिए हैं लेट्स सी
274 सब डोम चलिए 274 वर्किंग डोम हमें मिल
चुके हैं बहुत बढ़िया है बहुत अच्छी बात
है नाउ वी आर गोइंग टू रन वी आर गोइंग टू
रन यहां पे स्क्रीनशॉटिंग यहां
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग हम स्टार्ट कर देंगे हम
क्या करेंगे स्क्रीनशॉटिंग स्टार्ट करने
वाले हैं चलिए तो स्क्रीनशॉटिंग स्टार्ट
करते हैं स्क्रीनशॉटिंग स्टार्ट करने के
लिए यहां पे हम आई विटनेस का यूज करने
वाले हैं तो सुडो ए इंस्टॉल आई
विटनेस आई विटनेस एंड
दैट्ची इंस्टॉल हो रहा है जैसे ही हो
जाएगा व विल गो विद द आई विटनेस थिंग्स
ठीक है स्क्रीनशॉटिंग करने के
लिए टू ली बेकार
है सही है भाई टू ली बेकार है ये भी सही
है ये होती है पॉजिटिव टूल ही बेकार है
करेक्ट टूल तो अच्छा है बट अभी कुछ
प्रॉब्लम हो रहे होंगे ट्स वई इश्यूज आ
रहे हैं राइट और कोई बात नहीं
है यस यू कैन यूज प्योर डीएनएस मास डीएनएस
यूज कर सकते हो प्योर डीएनएस यूज कर लो जो
भी यूज करना है ऑल डीएनएस यूज कर लो जो
टूल्स यूज करना है सब डोमेन ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग के लिए आप पर्टिकुलर यूज कर सकते
हो
अ अल्टरनेट ऑफ शफल डीएनएस यू कैन यूज पयो
डीएनएस प्योर डीएनएस मास
डीएनएस यू कैन यूज ल्ट डीएनएस ऐसे टूल्स
जो है आप यूज कर सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं चलिए यहां पर हो चुका
हमारा डन आई विटनेस डन अब आई विटनेस को
लंच कर लेते हैं आई
विटनेस हमने लंच कर लिया नाउ वी हैव आई
विटनेस यर अब आई विटनेस को यूज कर लेते
हैं वेब एंड फाइल का नाम देना हान एफ से
हान एफ से ठीक है चलिए आई विटनेस नफन वेब
हान f फाइल नेम दे देते हैं
लाला एकटी इस पे करेगा एंड यहां पे हमें
टाइम आउट का थोड़ा इंक्रीज करना होगा हाई
फन हा फन टाइम आउट नहीं तो जल्दी ही हो
जाएगा यह टाइम आउट तो हाई फन हाई फन टाइम
आउट इसको रख देते हैं 30 सेकंड जैसा कि
मैंने आपको बताया था 30 सेकंड क्या रखते
हैं इसको 15 सेकंड भी रख दो बहुत बहुत है
15 सेकंड रख देते हैं देन थ्रेडिंग को आप
बढ़ा सकते हैं थ्रेड्स को आप बढ़ा सकते
हैं लाइक इफ यू वांट अभी फिलहाल के लिए हम
इसको डिफॉल्ट छोड़ देते हैं थ्रेड बढ़ा
सकते हैं आप चाहे तो रिजॉल्व वगैरह कर
सकते हैं ठीक है हटाओ अभी कुछ भी हम नहीं
कर रहे वी आर नॉट डूइंग एनीथिंग
ओके बाकी कुछ तो करना नहीं है बाकी सब डन
है बढ़िया चलिए सब कुछ डन हो गया अब हम
एंटर कर देते हैं एंड लेट्स सी द रिजल्ट्स
जस्ट वेट फॉर द रिजल्ट्स सो इट्स
स्टार्टिंग वेब रिक्वेस्ट कैपचरिंग 274
होस्ट का यह कैपचरिंग स्टार्ट कर चुका है
अटेम्प्टिंग टू स्क्रीनशॉट स्क्रीनशॉट
लेना स्टार्ट कर चुका है एंड इट विल
स्टार्ट कैपचरिंग जितने भी स्क्रीनशॉट ये
ले सकता है ये लेगा ठीक है तो ये ले रहा
है स्क्रीनशॉट यहां पे चलिए इसको
स्क्रीनशॉट लेने देते हैं स्क्रीनशॉटिंग
में थोड़ा टाइम लगता है गाइस आप लोकल
सिस्टम पे करोगे और भी टाइम लगेगा बहुत
स्लो स्लो स्लो स्लो स्लो स्लो टाइप होती
है राइट
ओके यहां पर टाइम आउट य प थोड़ा सा टाइम
आउट हो गया तो मैं एक काम करता हूं मैं
टाइम आउट को और भी बढ़ा देता हूं यहां पर
30 सेकंड का सही था 30 सेकंड का हमारा
जो टाइम आउट था वो सही था 30 सेकंड हमने
रख दिया एंड नाउ वी विल
वेट ठीक है तो इस तरीके से स्क्रीनशॉट आ
जाएगी अब मुझे एक बात बताओ ये जो
स्क्रीनशॉट आएगी यह तो आपके सील आई में आ
रही है यहां पे कमांड लाइन इंटरफेस है ठीक
है अब मुझे ये बताओ मुझे इस स्क्रीनशॉट को
लाइव वेब पे देखना है कैसे देखेंगे मुझे
ये बताओ जरा देखते हैं कितने लोग बता पाते
हैं बताइए मुझे कितने कैसे देखूंगा मैं
वेब
पे आ रही है ना फीलिंग हैकिंग वाली क्या
बात है चलिए अब मुझे बताइए वेब पे ये
स्क्रीनशॉट्स में है यह तो यार स्क्रीनशॉट
है यह जो आ रहा है स्क्रीनशॉट बन के आएगा
डायरेक्टरी में एक इसको मैं काली के
टर्मिनल में कैसे देख लूंगा यहां कोई
ब्राउजर सपोर्ट तो है नहीं अब ऐसा तो है
नहीं कि फाइल वहां से कॉपी पेस्ट मार दोगे
विंडोज में ऐसे ये कमांड लाइन है भाई यह
बताओ मु मुझे कैसे देखोगे स्क्रीनशॉट्स
देखते हैं कितने लोग क्या बताते
हैं
बताइए देखते हैं कितने लोगों का क्या आंसर
आता
है एचटीएमएल फाइल नहीं आएगी इसमें इसमें
एटीएल फाइल नहीं आएगी तो अब बताओ बताओ
एचटीएल फाइल नहीं आएगी मान
लो अब मुझे
बताओ हो रही है अब स्क्रीनशॉटिंग फटाफट
देख लो कुछ कुछ डोमस में थोड़े स्लो हो गए
थे बट यहां हो रहा
है हां ठीक है बट मुझे मान लो एचटीएमएल
फाइल नहीं आई एक्वाटोन यूज नहीं कर रहा
मैं इसी पे यूज कर रहा हूं मान लो मुझे आय
टनेस ही यूज करनी है कोटोन यूज नहीं करनी
अब बताओ मुझे नाउ लेट मी
नो बताइए बताइए हेल्प से चलिए देखिए मैं
आपको बता देता हूं
अ मैं आपको बताता हूं फिलहाल हमें
डायरेक्टर ब्रूट फोर्स के लिए ही जाना है
बट अभी फिलहाल के लिए बस हम यह यूज़ कर
रहे हैं और कुछ नहीं है फिलहाल के लिए यह
यह वाला हम यूज़ कर रहे हैं ठीक
है स्क्रीनशॉटिंग बस आपको दिखाने के लिए
मैं कर रहा हूं हमें स्क्रीनशॉट्स पे अभी
ध्यान नहीं देना है हमें अभी आगे बढ़ना है
तो हम डायरेक्टली ब्रूट फोर्सिंग वगर पे
ज्यादा फोकस करने वाले हैं
राइट अब देखिए यहां पे मान लो इतने
स्क्रीन हमारे पास आ गए मान लो 10 15 जो
भी है आ ग आ
ग बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग अभी बताने वाला हूं
मान लो इतने स्क्रीनशॉट्स आ गए हमारे पास
इतने पे मैं स्टॉप कर देता हूं मैंने
स्टॉप कर दिया ठीक है अब यहां पे मैं एलएस
करता हूं लिस्ट करता हूं यहां पे एक
डायरेक्टरी बन गई होगी डायरेक्टरी बन गई
यहां पे चलिए बढ़िया है दो डायरेक्टरी बन
गई है बेसिकली तो मैं एक काम करता हूं ना
जिसमें ज्यादा है उस वाले डायरेक्टरी को
रखता हूं जिसमें कम है उसको मैं रिमूव कर
देता हूं तो मैं सीडी 2024 में चलता हूं
यहां
पे 64 वाली डायरेक्टरी यह शायद पहले वाली
थी इसमें शायद कम होंगे शायद
सीडी यहां पर चलते हैं सीडी स्क्रीन एलस
करता हूं मैं यहां पर बस तीन है यहां प बस
और कुछ नहीं मुझे पता था इसमें ज्यादा
नहीं होंगे यहां पर मैं सीडी करता हूं
2024 वाले में
सॉरी 204 में 51 के बाद यहां पर कौन सा
था सेन तो सेन वाले में चलते हैं यहां पर
एलस करते हैं एंड यहां पर स्क्रीन में
चलते हैं एंड यहां पे एलएस करेंगे तो यहां
पे बहुत सारे स्क्रीनशॉट्स हैं ठीक है अब
देखो इतने सारे स्क्रीनशॉट्स है तुम्हारे
पास ये सारे अब इसको तुम कमांड लाइन में
तो देख नहीं पाओगे तो इसका एक तरीका क्या
है मैं आपको बताता हूं इसका तरीका है वेब
सर्वर को स्टार्ट कर देना वेब सर्वर को
स्टार्ट कर दीजिए सिंपल सा फंडा
है अब वेब सर्वर को कैसे स्टार्ट करेंगे
चलिए अब देखते हैं पहले यहां एलएस करता
हूं मैं यहां पे ही ये है तो पहले तो मैं
ये डायरेक्टरी रिमूव कर देता हूं ये आरएम
i r 2024 एंड सिक्स वाली डायरेक्टरी जो है
इसको कंप्लीट रिमूव कर देता हूं अब एक
डायरेक्टरी बनी हमारे पास यह वाली हम यहीं
पे वेब सर्वर स्टार्ट करेंगे अब वेब सर्वर
को स्टार्ट करने के लिए हम
python's इट आपका काम यहां पे हो जाना
चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से चलिए तो अब क्या करते
हैं python3 h m
http.sys न डॉट डॉट डॉट डॉट पोर्ट 8000 यह
आपकी सर्विंग एचटीटीपी यहां पर आपका
एचटीटीपी जो है यह सर्व हो रहा है
एचटीटीपी सर्वर स्टार्ट हो चुका है अब
इसको हमें क्या करना है हमें यहां पर ओपन
करना है अब ओपन कैसे करेंगे भाई कौन सा यह
आईपी है देखो इस आईपी पर एक बार ट्राई
करो वी हैव द आईपी कहां गई आईपी
हमारी तो हम यहां पर आईपी निकालेंगे
सॉरी यहां पर हम कर देंगे 8000 पोर्ट ठीक
है 8000 पोर्ट प वी विल ट्राई टू
फेच ठीक है ओके ओके ये कौन सी आईपी है
यार सॉरी सॉरी यह कौन सी आईपी हमने खोल दी
यार कौन सी आईपी हमने ले ली थी अरे
यार एक काम करते हैं जस्ट गो हियर
स्लश
गिव
इट सॉरी
8000 कोई बात नहीं अनुराग कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है एक बार इसी पर चलते हैं एक
बार
पब्लिक डीएनएस से नहीं तो हम पब्लिक
डीएनएस से ही चला लेते हैं एक बार ओपन
एड्रेस
हेयर
आ विल ट्राई टू यूटिलाइज ये डायरेक्टली
एक्सेस नहीं हो पाएगा क्योंकि यहां पर आई
हैव द
आईपी
राइट वी हैव द आईपी एड्रेस हियर एंड इट
शुड बी ओपनिंग टू
8000 लेट्स
वेट
ट्राई टू ओपन दी प्राइवेट
आईपी 80 नहीं है
यार 80 नहीं है 8000 पोर्ट है दिस पोर्ट इ
8000 य देखो 8000 पोर्ट लिखा हुआ रहा है
यू कन सी
र
या इट
[संगीत]
विल यह ओपन नहीं होगा इस तरीके से
आपका इट विल नॉट ओपन
बिकॉज 88000 पोर्ट यार है 8080 मत करो 88
मत करो क्योंकि यह बेसिकली हमारे लिए
एक्सटर्नल एनवायरमेंट हो जा रहा है तो यह
ओपन नहीं हो पाएगा इस तरीके से राइट इट
विल नॉट ओपन लाइक दिस क्योंकि एक्सटन
एनवायरमेंट हो रहा है यहां पे आप सर्व कर
भी रहे हो तो इससे कोई फायदा आपका हो नहीं
रहा है बेसिकली इट विल इट इज नॉट गेटिंग
बेनिफिटेड एंड ये हमारे मशीन पे कंफिल
नहीं है सबसे बड़ी बात है हमारा मशीन इनके
एनवायरमेंट में नहीं है आवर मशीन इज नॉट
इनसाइड दिस एनवायरमेंट राइट जो एनवायरमेंट
हमारा ये स2 का है हमारा जैसे हम ट्राई
हैक म में कर रहे थे ना हमारा एक
एनवायरमेंट था वो एनवायरमेंट हमें यहां पे
नहीं मिल रहा है ये हमारा एनवायरमेंट नहीं
है
दैट्ची
ओके इट विल नॉट हैपन इट विल नॉट ओपन इस
तरीके
से चलिए अब चलिए ठीक है कोई बात नहीं इस
तरह सर कैसे हो आज मैं लेट हो गया अरे ठीक
है भाई इतना स्पैम तो मत करो यार प्लीज
प्लीज डोंट स्पैम मैं देख लिया देख लिया
ठीक है कोई बात नहीं लेट हो गए कोई बात
नहीं स्पैम मत करो ठीक
है ठीक है
गॉट नहीं होगा नहीं होगा नहीं
होगा अ नहीं होगा नहीं होगा यहां पे हमें
बेसिकली वी वी कैन नॉट एक्सेस दिस वन वी
कैन नॉट एक्सेस दिस वन बिकॉज ये जो हमारी
देखो यहां पे समझने वाली बात क्या है
एक्सेस नहीं कर पा रहे हैं इसका रीजन मैं
बता देता हूं आपको यहां पे ये जो आईपी
सर्वर स्टार्ट हुई है यह हमारे यहां पे
आईएफ कॉन्फिडो आईएफ
कॉन्फिडो यस कर लेते हैं यहां पे यहां पे
आईपी दिखाता हूं मैं आपको आईएफ
कॉन्फिडो यहां पे तो तुम्हें एक इंटरनल
आईपी एड्रेस जो यहां पे मिल रही है ये ये
वाली आईपी 17231 3517 जो आईपी आपको यहां
पे भी देखने को मिलेगी जो यहां पे आपको
इंस्टेंस की आईपी मिली हुई है ये सेम आईपी
आपको देखने अब ये क्या है ये एडब s जो है
ना आपका इंस्टेंस उसकी आईपी है ये अब इसको
कोई बाहर से मशीन एक्सेस कर पाए इसके लिए
हमें यहां पे कुछ रूल्स डिफाइन करने
पड़ेंगे एंड जब वो रूल्स डिफाइन करेंगे हम
सेट कर देंगे तब ही ओनली यह काम करेगा अदर
वाइज इट विल नॉट वर्क सिंपल सी ये सिंपल
सा फंडा है अदर वाइज इट विल नॉट वर्क रूल
डिफाइन किए बिना आप इसको नहीं एक्सेस कर
सकते हैं बाहर से यानी कि आपको इंटरनल आउट
आउटवर्क्स के लिए रूफ डिफाइन करना पड़ेगा
कि कोई बाहर से आ रहा है तो उसको भैया हम
एक्सेस दे सकते हैं उसको हम एक्सेस दे
जैसे कि मैं आपको बताता हूं कैसा मैं बात
कर जैसे आपने जो मशीन यह बनाई हुई थी तो
यहां पर आप सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप्स आपने देखा
होगा ठीक है ये सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप्स आपकी
बनी हुई है यह वाली
[संगीत]
आपकी हमारी कौन सी है सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप
यहां
पे मैं यहां पर दिखा देता हूं यहां पे
हमारी जो सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप है यह है यह
ऑटोजन ठीक है 5429 ए ठीक है काली इक्स ये
वाली सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप है इस पे जब आप
जाएंगे ना सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप पे तो यहां पे
देखो यहां पे सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप में क्या
है यहां पे एटीपी और एचटीटीपीएस वैसे
इनेबल्ड है सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप में 80 पोर्ट
के लिए एंड 443 पोर्ट के लिए ये दो
पोर्ट्स के लिए जो है हमारा ये इनेबल्ड है
ठीक है कौन सा एसटीटीपी और एचटीटीपीएस ये
दोनों इनेबल्ड है आउट बाउंड रूल्स में
देखोगे तो आउट बाउंड रूल्स में सारे
ट्रैफिक हैं कोई बात नहीं इन बाउंड रूल्स
में ये ट्रैफिक हमारे नहीं है यहां पे ये
सेट नहीं है यहां पे अब मान लो यहां पे
चलो यहां पे क्या करते हैं एडिट पे चलते
हैं यहां पे एडिट इन बाउंड रूल्स पे यहां
पे यहां पे इन बाउंड रूल्स में हम एडिट पे
आ ग अब यहां पे इन बाउंड रूल में
एचटीटीपीएस है एटीटीपी है लेकिन ये किस
पोर्ट के लिए है भैया स्पेसिफिक यहां पे
टीसीपी पोर्ट 4438 ये दो पोर्ट्स के लिए
यहां पे स्पेसिफिकली मेंशन है अब हम एक
ट्राई करते हैं यहां पे ट्राई क्या करते
हैं ऐड रूल करते हैं यहां पे एंड यहां पे
कस्टम टीसीपी यहां पे एक बार ऐड डाल देते
हैं ऑल टीसीपी कर लेते हैं कस्टम टीसीपी
डाल देते हैं जो भी आपकी मर्जी है वो डाल
दीजिए कोई दिक्कत यहां पे ठीक है तो मैं
यहां पे कर देता हूं
एचटीटीपी यहां पे हमने पाइथन एडीपी सर्वर
डाउ इंस्टॉल कर लिया एटीटीपी हमें चाहिए
ठीक है लेट्स क्लोज इट फर्स्ट हम यहां पे
एक एसटीटीपी रूल लगा देते हैं वी विल
ट्राई टू इन बाउंड रूल सेट कर देते हैं
एसटीडीपी
का ठीक है एंड यहां पे
यह बाय डिफॉल्ट इट इज टेकिंग द एटी पोर्ट
वी हैव टू मूव इट टू सम अदर
पोर्ट कस्टम
टीसीपी यहां पे कस्टम टीसीपी पोर्ट डाल
देते हैं क्योंकि एसटीटीपी में क्या हो
रहा है कि ये बाय डिफॉल्ट 80 ही ले ले रहा
है तो हमारा यहां पे जो है ना पोर्ट नंबर
यह पोर्ट नंबर क्या होना चाहिए 8000 होना
चाहिए 8000 पोर्ट को ये हमारे को अलाउ
करना चाहिए सिंपल तो कस्टम टीसीपी डाल
देते हैं अगर क्योंकि आप अगर ऑल टीसीपी भी
कर सकते हैं हालांकि तो ये सारे टीसीपी
पोर्ट्स को अलाउ कर देगा लेकिन फिलहाल
यहां पे आप कस्टम में आके कोई से भी आईपी
आप चूज कर लीजिए बट यहां पे क्या है ना हम
यहां पे कर देते
हैं कस्टम टीसीपी एंड पोर्ट नंबर दे देते
हैं 8000 8000 पोर्ट को हम यहां पे अलाउ
कर देते हैं एंड दिस इज अ एनी वेयर आईपी
फॉर एड्रेस कर देते हैं यहां पे एंड यहां
पे डिस्क्रिप्शन डाल सकते हैं यहां पे बस
दैट्ची हो गया यहां पे 8000 पोर्ट पे सेव
रूल्स पे क्लिक कर देते हैं नाउ लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग चलिए मॉडिफाइड ऑन
सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप ये मॉडिफाई हो चुकी है
यहां पे अब यह मॉडिफाइड जो हो चुकी है अब
यह यहां पे हमारे इंस्टेंस पे हो सक देखते
हैं एक बार अगर
यह आपका एप्लीकेबल हो गया
होगा सेव चेंजेज तो लेट्स ट्राई टू
सी हमने यहां पे इन बाउंड रूड रूट सेट रूल
सेट किया है नाउ वी आर गोइंग हियर क्लियर
हियर नाउ वी आर गोइंग टू एटीटीपी सर्वर
यहां पर कर देते हैं यहां पर एंड अब जो है
हम इसको इसके पब्लिक आईपी से एक्सेस करने
की कोशिश करते हैं लेट्स ट्राई टू एक्सेस
द कॉलन
8000 एंड नाउ वी कैन एक्सेस इट गट इट अब
हम यहां पर सारे फाइल्स को एक्सेस कर पा
रहे हैं सभी लोग देख पा रहे हैं पब्लिक
आईपी से 8000 पोर्ट प वी कैन एक्सेस नाउ
एवरीवन कैन सी
हियर एवरीवन कैन सी
हियर अब देख स
सारी काली की फाइल आ गई भैया स्क्रीनशॉट
वाली य देखो 2 मिलियन सब डोमेन एंड ल यह
सारी चीज आप आ गई आपकी आप देख सकते हो
यहां पर यह वाली फोल्डर आ गई सारी
स्क्रीनशॉट य स्क्रीन आ गए आपके य
स्क्रीनशॉट्स यू कैन सी
गाइस एवरीवन कैन सी जल्दी बता दीजिए मुझे
जल्दी लेट मी नो फास्ट
गाइस सो बेसिकली क्या है इन बाउंड रूल में
सेट करना भूल गया था एंड मुझे ध्यान
बिल्कुल नहीं था इन बाउंड रूल सेट करना है
क्योंकि हमारा पोर्ट यहां डिफरेंट आ रहा
था 8000 पोर्ट आ रहा था एंड इन बाउंड रूल
में 8000 पोर्ट था नहीं
राइट
कट सो इन बाउंड रून के लिए
मुझे नोटिस कराया
था किसने किसीने नोटिस कराया था मुझे मयंक
मयंक तो थैंक यू मयंक नोटिस कराने के लिए
इन बाउंड रूल वाले मेरे दिमाग में बिल्कुल
भी नहीं था बिकॉज 8000 पोर्ट पर हम काम कर
रहे थे और हमारा रूल ऑलरेडी सेट था इन
बाउंड रूल में क्या होता है मैं आपको समझा
दूंगा वैसे बहुत ज्यादा अभी डीप नहीं जा
रहे हैं बट इन रूल में था कि 80 पोर्ट
नंबर जो था 8443 एंड ये सब हमारा एक्सेप्ट
कर रहा था ट्रैफिक को पट 22 भी कर रहा था
बट 8000 नहीं कर पा रहा था इसलिए हमें
8000 को अलाउ करना पड़ा एंड देन वी कैन
एक्सेस इट राइट
ओके सो ओके सो शाउट आउट टू मयंक एंड
थैंक्स मयंक ठीक ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पर
हमारे पास स्क्रीनशॉट्स आ गई है नाउ यू
कैन जस्ट यूज यू कैन जस्ट चेक द
स्क्रीनशॉट्स जो भी स्क्रीनशॉट्स है आपके
पास आप चेक आउट कर सकते हैं भैया कि कौन
सा स्क्रीनशॉट है क्या है क्या आपके सामने
क्या दिख रहा है इस पर्टिकुलर स्क्रीनशॉट
पे यह सारे स्क्रीनशॉट आप देखो यह डीएनएस
फेलियर यह
वाली यह
है ईपीए गेटवे वी डोंट हैव द परमिशन टू
व्यू द गेटवे यह सब चीजें ठीक
है ओके
चलिए चलिए
बढ़िया अब ये स्क्रीनशॉट आप देख सकते हैं
अब मैंने जो इन बाउंड वाला अभी यहां पे
किया था मैं आपको एक जस्ट सिंपल सा बता
देता हूं क्या होता क्या किया था मैंने आप
जब कोई मशीन को लंच करेंगे तो उसकी एक
सिक्योरिटी सेटिंग होती है यहां पे आएंगे
तो सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप्स होता है ठीक है
सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप पे क्लिक कीजिएगा तो
इसकी सेटिंग ओपन हो जाएगी यहां पे कुछ
रूल्स डिफाइन होते हैं इन बाउंड रूल तो
इसी को मैंने एडिट किया था बस एंड यहां पर
मैंने एक अलग से कस्टम टीसीपी का रूल डाला
है एंड इसमें मैंने बोला है कि 8 पोर्ट को
अलाउ किया जाए किसी भी आईपी से बस बात
खत्म क्योंकि 80 22 और 443 अलाउड था 8000
अलाउड नहीं था तो हमारा सर्वर लच नहीं हो
पा रहा था सर्वर काम नहीं कर पा रहा था तो
अब हमने सर्वर से यहां पे एक्सेस भैया
डायरेक्टरी लिस्टिंग कर दी है एंड हम इस
सर्वर को एक्सेस कर पा रहे हैं सो वी गट
दिस ठीक है तो यह चीज आपकी हो गई अब यहां
पर बात आते हैं डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
की नाउ वी आर गोइंग टू
डू डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग लेकिन उसके
पहले भी ये काम करेंगे ज देखो अच्छा एक
चीज तुम्हें पता है मैं एक चीज बता देता
हूं पता नहीं आप लोगों को कितने लोगों को
पता है जैसे मुझे
python3 h m
अ थिंग मैं यह चाहता हूं डिफ्रॉक सर्वर या
सीधा सर्वर लिखो और वह पूरा कमांड रन कर
दे इसको हम बोलते हैं एलियास सेट करना
एलिया सेट करके आप यह काम कर सकते हैं यू
कैन डू दिस थिंग्स एलियास सेट करके कैसे
एलियास कैसे सेट करते हैं यह भी बताता हूं
जानना है चलिए एलियास को अब सेट करते हैं
कैसे एक पूरे कमांड एक बड़े से कमांड के
बदले एक छोटा कमांड कैसे लाते हैं यह
ऑटोमेशन में काफी हेल्प करता है तो यह काम
कैसे करते हैं जैसे मेरे पास यह पूरा
कमांड है अब मुझे इसका छोटा सा एक कमांड
बना देना है इसके लिए आपको एक चीज करनी
पड़ेगी वह क्या करनी पड़ेगी मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं सिंपल आपको z एसएचआरसी जो आपकी
फाइल थी उसके अंदर एक एलियास को सेट करना
पड़ेगा और एलियास को सेट करने का तरीका
क्या है वो भी आपको दिखाते हैं तो चलिए
नैनो स्पेस जेएसए आरसी में चलते हैं यहां
जब आप नीचे आएंगे तो यहां पे ऑलरेडी एलियस
बने होंगे देखिए
जैसे लेट्स गो डाउन गो डाउन गो डाउन गो
डाउन गो डाउन गो डाउन गो
डाउन चलिए ये देखिए एलियस बने यहां पे
एलियस एलियस एलियस ये सारे बने हुए हैं
चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां देखिए यह एलिस बने
हुए यहां प सम मोर एलस एलिस अब यहां पर
मुझे एक एलियस बनाना है
चलिए यहां पर एलियस मैंने बना दिया अब
यहां पर टाइप क्या करना है एलियस बनाते
टाइम
एलियस ठीक है अब आपको जो कमांड आपको देना
है वह कमांड यहां पर डालना है मुझे किस
छोटे से कमांड से पूरा बड़ा कमांड रन करना
है तो मैं क्या करता हूं डिफक सर्वर
चनाना डि फरोनिक्स
सर्वर यह कमांड से मैं चाहता हूं कि
python2 देना है और दो ब्रैकेट के अंदर अब
आपको वो कमांड दे देनी है जो कमांड आपको
चलानी है तो मैं एक
python3 पड सवर ये वाली आपको कमांड दे
देनी है
दैट्ची फाइल में आपने ये जब डाल दिया
मैंने आपको दो चीजें बताई ज जेएसए आरसी की
एक तो आपका पाथ सेट करना बता दिया सबसे
लास्ट में सेट किया था गो का और ये एलिया
सेट करना कोई भी कमांड का छोटा छोटा सा
आपको शॉर्ट फॉर्म आपको चला देना है बैस
स्क्रिप्टिंग का ही पार्ट है राइट छोटा सा
आपको वो कर देना है ठीक है तो अब यहां पे
आ गए एलिस नक सर्वर और पूरी कमांड
python-tk जरूर कीजिएगा नहीं तो वो इफेक्ट
में नहीं आएगी या तो रिबूट कर दीजिएगा
सोर्स कर दिया हो गया अब मैं सिर्फ डिक्स
सर्वर टाइप करूंगा ना एंटर
करूंगा ओके क्या दिक्कत आ रही
है पाइथन 3 मॉड्यूल नॉट फाउंड यह क्या
है व्हाट इज दिस पाइथन अभी पाइथन सर्वर
स्टार्ट तो किया था
हमने यह वाली चीज सर्वर जो है स्टार्ट तो
की थी हमने
hp3 h m सो व्हाट इज द व्हाट इज द
इशू चलिए एक बार चलते हैं न जए आरसी में
एक बार देख लेते
हैं एक बार देखते हैं प्रॉब्लम क्या है
भाई कुछ हमने कुछ यहां पे गलती की है कुछ
ना कुछ तो गलत किया है यहां पे जए आरसी
फाइल में जब हमने कन्फर किया है तो एलियस
में लेट्स
चेक अरे यार हमने यहां पे python3 नहीं
दिया है भाई यहां सिर्फ पाइथन दे दिया है
तो य python3 देना है ना python3 h m
http.com सर्वर एंड इट शुड जस्ट लॉन्च
एटीटीपी सर्वर एंड आपका एटीटीपी सर्वर लॉच
हो गया सिर्फ एक डिफर सर्वर किया एन स ये
बैस स्क्रिप्टिंग का ही पार्ट है एक
ऑटोमेशन का पार्ट है ऑटोमेट कर पाते हैं अ
इस बड़े-बड़े कमांड्स को छोटा कर देते हैं
बड़े-बड़े वन लाइनर्स को एक छोटे कमांड से
आप रन कर सकते हैं एंड आपका ये ट्रॉनिक्स
ये सर्वर जो है वो स्टार्ट हो चुका है ट्स
इट इस सर्वर की खासियत यह है गाइस कि जिस
लोकेशन पे आप रहेंगे उसी लोकेशन पे आपकी
सर्वर रन हो जाएगी जैसे अगर मेरा लोकेशन
देखो मैं मैं है ना मैं क्या करता हूं मैं
इस फोल्डर में चला जाता हूं 2024 वाले
फोल्डर में जाता हूं यहां पे यह स्क्रीन
वाले में चला जाता हूं सीडी स्क्रीन अब
मैं यहां पर जाके सिर्फ स्क्रीनशॉट्स है
ना यहां पर अगर मैं सर्वर चलाऊंगा तो मेरे
सिर्फ यही वाली पार्ट लच होगी यही वाली
पार्ट जो है वह यहां पर आपकी दिखेगी चलिए
देख लीजिए अगेन हम इसको रीलोड कर देते हैं
8000 वाली देखिए ये सिर्फ स्क्रीनशॉट ओपन
हुई और कुछ नहीं ओपन होगी पहले पूरा
डायरेक्टरी ओपन हो रहा था अभ सिर्फ
स्क्रीनशॉट वाली फोल्डर ओपन होगी जिस
लोकेशन प आप ये सर्वर चलाएंगे उसी लोकेशन
को एक्सपोज करता है ये इसकी खासियत है यह
समझ में आ
गया एवरीवन गट
एवरीवन अंडरस्टूड व्हाट वी जस्ट डिड हमने
जो भी अभी किया सभी लोगों को समझ में आया
कि नहीं आया बता दीजिए जल्दी से जल्दी
बताइए जल्दी बताइए जल्दी बताइए एवरीवन
बताइए चलिए यह तो काम हो गया भैया अब आते
हैं हमारे डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के
लिए वी आर गोइंग टू सी डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग कैसे करना है डीआर सर्च का यूज
करेंगे या फिर एफएफ यूएफ का भी यूज कर
सकते हैं जो आपकी मर्जी यहां हम यू करने
वाले हैं डीआर सर्च वन ऑफ द बेस्ट टूल एंड
वन ऑफ द मोस्ट इंटरेस्टिंग टूल आई वुड से
राइट चलिए डीआर सर्च का यूज करेंगे तो
डियर सर्च हान एच एंड बढ़िया आ गया
आपका आज की क्लास बहुत शानदार है थैंक यू
थैंक यू ब्रदर आज की क्लास शेयर कर देना
यार आप लोग में से कितने लोग शेयर करते हो
यार सच सच बताना सच सच बताना शेयर करते हो
कि नहीं मतलब शेयर करोगे तो ही उसको
सपोर्ट मैं मानता हूं बहुत ज्यादा बड़ा
बहुत बड़ा सपोर्ट मानता हूं मैं
एंड जितनी शेयरिंग करोगे उतना सपोर्ट
मिलेगा
राइट हां यह भी होता है पाइथन i m सिंपल
एटीटीपी सर्वर यह भी होता है मिस्टर एक्स
बिल्कुल
ओके आई वुड आई वुड टेल एवरीवन ठीक है चलिए
सो शेयरिंग प्लीज कीजिएगा ज्यादा बहुत
अच्छा लगता है शेयरिंग आप करते हैं जितना
शेयरिंग करते हैं उतना अच्छा लगता है राइट
चलिए अब यहां पे हान ए पाथ दे देते हैं
यहां पे र सर्च पे र सर्च हान l एंड यहां
पे टेस्ला लाइव वाली जो है वो दे देते हैं
टेस्ला लाइव ठीक है एंड देन अब आपको क्या
करना
है हान e से एक्सटेंशंस को ऐड कर देने हैं
चलिए हान e दे देते हैं एक्सटेंशंस पीएचपी
डाल देते हैं एपी डाल देते हैं एप एक् डाल
देते हैं एंड देन और भी क्या डालते हैं
200 स्टेटस कोड्स को इंक्लूड करते हैं
मोस्टली या हान आई वड बी 200 राइट यस हान
आई से इंक्लूड स्टेटस कोड हम 200 कर देते
हैं थ्रेड को हम थोड़ा सा बढ़ा जरूर देंगे
यहां पे हाइन टी से हम थ्रेड को बढ़ा
देंगे हाइन टी से थ्रेड को हम 300 कर देते
हैं
एंड एंड एंड एंड
एंड एंड ट्स ट्स
इट ट्स इट फॉर नाउ गाइस बस इतना काफी है
इसके लिए चलिए 300 से हम इसको 200 कर देते
हैं 300 वड बी मच हायर एंड देन वी विल सी
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग एंड इट विल
स्टार्ट ब्रूट फोर्सिंग एंड लेट्स सी हर
एक सब डोमेन पे जो भी लिस्ट में है हमारे
यह ब्रूट फोर्सिंग करेगा एंड इट विल गिव
यू द रिजल्ट्स सो यहां पे ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
आपकी स्टार्ट हो चुकी है एंड यू कैन सी द
अ रिक्वेस्ट 400 तक भी जा रहे हैं अभी
फिलहाल अभी और भी जाएंगे कोई कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है एंड इट विल गिव यू अ वेरी वेरी
ग्रेट रिजल्ट राइट बहुत अच्छा रिजल्ट देगा
आपको ठीक
है थैंक यू
लाइक थैंक यू पंकज ब्रदर थैंक यू कॉलेज
ग्रुप में शेयर करने के लिए अच्छा मुझे आप
लोग तो बोल रहे हो शेयर करते हो यह हो रहा
है तब तक सच सच बताओ कहां-कहां शेयर करते
हो मुझे जरा बताना यार अभी लगभग 55 लोग
देख रहे हैं ना देखता हूं मैं आप लोग में
से कितने लोग क्या बोलते हैं कहां-कहां
शेयर करते हो बता दो मुझे इसी बात पे बताओ
देखते हैं इसी से पता चल जाएगा कि आपने
कहां शेयर किया देखिए जैसे एक का सब
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग हो चुकी है एक
की अब ये दूसरे वाले टारगेट पे मूव ऑन कर
चुका है वहां पे करेगा फिर तीसरे फिर चौथे
ऐसे करके ये करता जाएगा राइट तो ये
डायरेक्ट ब्रूट फोर्सिंग करते रहिए आप
आराम से वेट कीजिए सारे जो भी
इसकी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग है ये करेगा एंड इट
विल गिव यू द रिजल्ट्स
राइट अच्छी खासी पर सेकंड जो है थ्रेड चल
रही है
अभी जेएस भी आएगी जेएस भी आएगी यार जावा
फाइल जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल एनालिसिस भी आएगी
अभी सब डोमन टेकओवर भी आएगा अभी अभी तो
पता नहीं क्या क्या बाकी है यार अभी तो
बहुत कुछ बचा हुआ है अभी तो स्टार्ट हुआ
है भाई इंतजार
करो थैंक
यू चलो इट्स ्र ट ग्रुप नचके थैंक यू
शैलेश थैंक यू पियूष थैंक
यू थारा भाई जोगिंदर
धन्यवाद धन्यवाद भाई शेयरिंग के लिए आप
लोगों का ब बहुत-बहुत
धन्यवाद मिस्टर एक्स अपनी व कम्युनिटी में
थैंक यू मिस्टर एक्स थैंक यू सो मच जो भी
शेयर कर रहे हैं आप सबको बहुत-बहुत
धन्यवाद आपकी शेयरिंग से ही इतनी शानदार
रिस्पांस मिल रही है एंड इतना मैं आपको
आगे तक लेकर जा रहा हूं बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
चीजें अभी ठीक है अभी तो बहुत कुछ आना
बाकी है भाई सब डोमन टेक ओवर तो अभी आना
बाकी बाकी है सब डोमन टेकओवर की स्पेशल एक
क्लास होगी उसके लिए समझना पड़ेगा आपको
थोड़ी
बहुत
ठीक है चलिए यह भी हो गया देख रहे हैं आप
लोकल मशीन से कितना फास्ट तीन अभी भी हो
गया अभी लोकल मशीन प तो यह वैसे ही अभी
चलता ही रहता अभी पता नहीं क्या होता रहता
तो दिस वर्क लाइक दिस ऐसे इस तरीके से आप
बेसिकली क्लाउड में वीपीएस सेटअप करके यूज
कर सकते हैं काफी मजा आता है काफी फास्ट
भी आपका काम हो जाता है एंड काफी ज्यादा
फास्ट सब डोमस वग नरेट आप कर पाते हैं
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग हो जाता है ठीक है ट्स
इट
सो कौन गले स में आने के थैंक यू सो मच
थारा भाई जोगिंदर भाई थैंक
यू सभी लोग रिप्लाई नहीं करते यार यहां प
55 लोग है ना बट मुझे कुछ ही लोग के मैसेज
दिख रहे हैं यूनिक थारा भाई नचिकेत पंकज
ऑर्बिट अब्दुल मिस्टर एक्स पियूष शैलेश
इट्स डी लाइक पंकज यह लोग ही है बस बाकी
लोग कौन हो भाई बाकी लोग कौन हो रिप्लाई
तो करो बाकी लोग अपना नाम तो बताओ कौन हो
क्या नाम है आपका जो भी देख रहे हैं प्लीज
नाम बता दीजिएगा तोसे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
जो भी देख रहे प्लीज लेट मी नो योर
नेम प्लीज लेट मी
नो
गाइस डेवियन में भी आप इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हैं ना डेन में भी आप ये सारे इंस्टॉल कर
सकते हैं जैसे अभी आपने इंस्टॉल किया
ध्रुव राजीव राहुल
ग्रेट भूपेंद्र शैलेश चलिए अच्छी बात
है चलिए तो ये इस तरीके से डायरेक्टरी बड
फोर्सिंग आपकी इस तरी से बीपीएस में आपका
यह सारा काम होगा काफी फास्ट काम होता है
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग होता है एंड आप अगर
देखेंगे यहां पे मैं यहां पे क्लोज कर
देता हूं
ठीक
है चश्मा कहां है चमा चश्मा यही पर है यार
य चश्मा यह रहा
चश्मा दिस यर ट यह रही
चश्मा हैकर आइडेंटिटी नहीं बताते य कौन सी
हैकर हो भाई कहां के हैकर हो तुम फर्जी
हैकर हो तुम आइडेंटिटी जो नहीं
बताते यही बोलूंगा चलिए बुरा मत मानना बट
हो तो यार क्या बोल सकते हैं क्या
आइडेंटिटी है भाई आपकी दो मिनट में निकल
जाएगी आइडेंटिटी चलिए ठीक है दिल पे मत
लेना मजाक कर रहा
था
ओहो चलिए हो गया गाइस तो बस
दैट्ची सेटअप कर सकते हैं हां एक बात और
रखिएगा क्लाउड में आप अपने काली मशीन को
सेटअप कर सकते हैं मैं यहां पे एग्जिट हो
जाता हूं यहां पे कनेक्शन क्लोज हो जाएगा
यहां पे आप जब मशीन को क्लोज कर देंगे तो
आप याद रखिएगा इंस्टेंसस में जाइएगा
इंस्टेंसस में जाइएगा यहां आपका जो काली
मशीन है पहले आप इसको क्या कीजिएगा
सेलेक्ट कीजिएगा जो मशीन आपने ऑन की है यू
हैव टू जस्ट सेलेक्ट इट एंड यू हैव टू गो
टू इंस्टेंट स्टेट पे एंड यहां पे स्टॉप
कर देना है आपको स्टॉप स्टॉप जरूर कर
दीजिएगा स्टॉप करने के बाद अगर आपको इसको
परमानेंटली हटाना है ना तब जाके ही आप
इसको एक्शन इंस्टेंट स्टेट में जाके
टर्मिनेट कीजिएगा जब ये स्टॉप हो जाएगा
अभी स्टॉपिंग लिख रहा है अभी स्टॉप नहीं
हुआ है इसको अगर परमानेंटली डिलीट जब कर
देंगे टर्मिनेट कर देंगे ना तो इसका जो भी
डाटा होता है जो भी है सब डिलीट हो जाएगा
स्टॉप करेंगे तो पॉज हो जाता है फिर से आप
स्टार्ट करेंगे सारा कुछ आपका उसमें रहेगा
वैसे ही आपका काम करेगा ठीक है तो आप यहां
पे स्टॉप या जो भी है टर्मिनेट जो भी आपकी
मर्जी आप कर दीजिएगा परमानेंटली अगर हटाना
हो तो टर्मिनेट स्टॉप करके या तो सिर्फ
स्टॉप करके रहने दीजिएगा एंड याद रखिएगा
डेबिट कार्ड नॉट क्रेडिट कार्ड नेवर एंड
बिल आए तो मेल पे कर दीजिएगा कि मैं
स्टूडेंट हूं नहीं हो सकता भाई इतना
पेमेंट सॉरी माफ कीजिए भाई
दैट्ची जिए एंड यहां पे लिख रहा है कि ये
सारे टर्मिनेट हो जाएंगे टर्मिनेट पे
क्लिक कीजिए एंड इट विल स्टार्ट शटिंग
डाउन एंड इट विल बी टर्मिनेटेड फवर ठीक है
ट्स इट
सो चलिए यह तो हो गया एंड जिन लोगों ने
अभी अभी किसी
ने अभी किसी ने हमारे अभी किसी ने इनरोल
किया जहां तक मुझे
दिखा समवन एनरोल लेट्स
सी यस समवन रोल्ड कौन है यहां पर भाई किने
किहों किया ओके हर्ष चलिए ठीक है हर्ष
गोहिल ने इनरोल किया है हमारे
अ डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक मास्टरी ट्रेनिंग में
राइट डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक मास्टरी ट्रेनिंग
थ्री मंथ्स की ट्रेनिंग है या मैं आपको
फिर से बता देता हूं ये वाली लिंक जो है
मैं आपको फिर से यहां पे दे देता हूं यू
कैन गो टू दिस लिंक एंड यू कैन जस्ट इनरोल
टू दिस ट्रेनिंग 27th जनवरी से इसकी क्लास
स्टार्ट हो रही है बहुत कुछ सीखना है अभी
आपको बहुत कुछ इसमें बताया जाएगा वेरी
वेरी एडवांस थिंग्स यू विल सी फ्रॉम बेसिक
टू एडवांस एंड यू विल नॉट रिग्रेट बिकॉज
बहुत ही अफोर्डेबल रेट में आपको ये
ट्रेनिंग मिल रही है ऐसी रेट में कहीं
नहीं मिलती है कहीं भी आप जाइएगा 255000
से कम में आपको ये ट्रेनिंग नहीं मिलेगी
बस
दैट्ची वहां पे लाइव सेशंस होंगे डाउट
सेशंस होंगे सारे रिसोर्सेस उसी में
प्रोवाइड आपको किए जाएंगे ठीक है दैट्ची
ट्राक मी गिव अवे ऑन 10 के चलिए ट्राक मी
का गिव अवे देखते हैं कर देंगे
ओके 10 के तो आ
जाओ ओके तो ट्स इट गाइस फॉर
टुडे सो आज के सेशन के लिए बस इतना ही
एंड आ आ एम फ्रॉम नेपाल आई ऑलरेडी जॉइन जय
जय राम यस जय राम ग्रेट बहुत
बढ़िया अभिनव शर्मा हेलो निते इट्स नॉट
नितीश इट्स नितेश अभिनव दिस इज सीसी आईओ
अभिनव शर्मा ग्रेट अभिनव वेलकम टू दिस
सेशन चलिए सबको अभी के लिए बस इतना ही
सबको गुड नाइट एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन
में थैंक यू सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन
शेयर द सेशन विद योर फ्रेंड्स एंड जो भी
लोग इंटरेस्टेड है बग बाउंट सीखना चाहते
हैं बिगनर टू एडवांस लेवल सीखना चाहते हैं
बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट लेट देम नो अबाउट
दिस प्लेलिस्ट डेनिक्स अकेडमी और ये जो
सीरीज चल रही है उसके बारे में